Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Mo-Mo-Monka-Dumlin!
So.
Ich musste noch.
die Hühner vom Nachbar
füttern.
Die sind im Urlaub.
Und
da muss jemand die Hühner füttern.
Wobei es nicht nur Hühner füttern ist,
es ist auch Hühner Wasser geben und das Gehege
aufmachen und Zeug.
Die legen erstaunlich wenig Eier.
Guck jetzt schon seit einer Woche.
Wir sind quasi letztes Wochenende sind die glaube ich
weggefahren. Ich gucke jetzt da seit
einer Woche nach.
Und die haben es in einer Woche geschafft.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist nicht der. Das ist der auf der anderen Seite.
Ähm.
Und.
Die haben es jetzt geschafft, innerhalb von einer Woche
zwei Eier zu legen.
Und jetzt sitzen sie drauf und brüten
vor sich hin.
Ich glaube, das ist ziemlich wenig.
Die letzten, die der hatte, um die haben wir uns auch mal gekümmert.
Die haben Eier rausgehauen wie sonst was.
Ich mache meine Klimaanlage an.
Die ist übelst warm.
Naja, was heißt übelst warm?
27,5.
Das geht ja eigentlich noch, klar.
Im Vergleich zur letzten Woche.
30,5, 31.
Ja, die waren stets bemüht, genau.
Lass mal kurz den Mini-PC einschalten.
Also OBS geht mir auch schon echt hardcore auf den Sack mit dieser Meldung jedes Mal.
Kein Signal.
Gleich gibt es Signal.
Wenn der Mini-PC sich dazu entschieden hat,
jetzt mal anzufangen zu booten.
Also eingeschaltet habe ich ihn schon.
Sich dazu entscheiden, endlich mal anzufangen zu booten.
Chat gestern im Stream.
Ich glaube,
da war doch jemand da, der gemeint hat,
er will jetzt mit Linux anfangen
und neu und sonst was.
Und als ich da mein Setup erklärt habe
mit der Elgato Capture Card.
Ich glaube, das hat ihn etwas verwirrt.
Ich glaube, das war zu viel
des Guten.
Wobei das ja eigentlich mit Linux nicht viel zu tun hat.
Das ist eher ein OBS-Setup.
Aber ich dachte mir, ich erzähle es halt mal.
Das war aber glaube ich zu viel
des Guten.
Das ist ja auch schon ein bisschen durch die Brust
ins Auge, das Setup. Aber es funktioniert
gut. Das muss man
wirklich mal sagen.
Das ist das ist das ist perfekter Ersatz für meine VM.
Guck hier hier Linux im Fullscreen da Windows im Fullscreen.
Das heißt Fullscreen halt ein Bildschirm voll.
Linux und das ist keine VM das ist halt ein richtig echter Mini PC.
Richtig echter Mini PC mit 8 Kern AMD.
Und das kann ich halt hier einfach umschalten mit einem Makro auf der Tastatur zwischen
Windows-Hardware und Linux-Hardware und das ist kein KVM oder sowas.
Ich hab das hier wirklich auf zwei unterschiedlichen Desktops.
Freust du dich eigentlich über die neuen Regeln zur Krankschreibung?
Ich finde die total dämlich.
Aber mich betrifft es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Weil wir eine extra Regelung haben, dass wir erst ab dem dritten Tag was brauchen.
Ich meine, du kannst ja immer noch Zusatzregelungen treffen.
Ja, dazu.
Aber ich finde es so unglaublich dumm.
Die tun ja gerade so, als wäre das jetzt eine riesengroße Anzahl an Leuten, die ab und zu mal daheim bleiben.
Ja.
Das ist in der Summe von allen Krankschreibungen, was weiß ich, keine Ahnung, 5% wenn es hochkommt, sag ich jetzt einfach mal.
Das wird nicht allzu viel sein.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, das sind 1%.
Und...
Moin.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, glaube ich nicht, dass es dazu führen wird, dass die Leute weniger krank sind.
Ich glaube eher, dass das dazu führen wird, dass die sagen, ey, wenn ich jetzt schon zum Arzt gehen muss,
mal angenommen, einer hatte nachts übelst krass Dünnschiss, hat nicht richtig gepennt,
sag ich, bleib mal einen Tag zu Hause, der ist eigentlich schon an dem Tag wieder halbwegs fit,
kann aber nicht arbeiten gehen, weil vielleicht noch
Überreste davon
ab Start sind oder halt so im Arsch ist,
dass er sich mal einen Tag ausruhen muss.
Wenn der dann zum Arzt gehen muss,
oder mal angenommen, der hat noch Dünnschiss,
mal angenommen, der geht dann zum Arzt,
dann geht der zum Arzt und sagt,
boah, ey, ganze Nacht
hier Dünnschiss gehabt, ist immer noch nicht besser,
mir geht's zu schlecht.
Und dann sagt der Arzt, weil er keinen Bock hat,
dass das ganze Wartezimmer
nur mit solchen Leuten voll ist,
dann sagt der Arzt, ja, was meinen sie denn, bis wann wieder gut ist
dann sagt der dann am Montag, ja, ich denke mal bis Ende der Woche
und dann sagt der Arzt, bam, ok, ich schreibe sie bis inklusive Freitag krank
nice
und wenn die Pech, das wollte ich ja auch gerade sagen, ja
und wenn die Pech haben
also wenn der Arbeitgeber dann Pech hat
dann sitzt er im Wartezimmer
und holt sich noch eine Erkältung, ist auch noch eine zweite Woche krank
das wird passieren
also ich kann mir beim besten Willen nicht
vorstellen, dass das unterm
Strich
die Anzahl der Krankheitstage
reduzieren wird, ist genauso
wie
mit dieser Geschichte, dass
Tankstellen
die Preise nur noch senken dürfen, irgendwie nur noch
Mitternacht erhöhen dürfen oder irgendwie sowas
das hat ja auch nichts gebracht, witzigerweise
haben das ja im Vorfeld auch ganz viele
gesagt, dass die Regelung nichts bringen wird, aber
wir machen das trotzdem
Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
Dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise dazu führt
Dass die Leute wirklich weniger krank sind
Also wozu sie das machen
Weiß nicht
Und wisst ihr was mich auch extremst abfuckt
Bei der ganzen Sache
Man hat ja das Gefühl
Wenn man ganz normal arbeiten geht
dann ist man ja
krass sehr gearscht, egal in welchen Fällen
du bezahlst
ultra viel Steuern und Abgaben
und wirst jetzt auch laufend
noch mit jedem Scheiß gegängelt
da bleibt ja
da bleibt ja bloß noch
Harzen kann man jetzt ja nicht mehr sagen
da bleibt ja nur noch
Teilzeit oder Harzen, ey
Also Teilzeit mache ich ja schon seit Jahren
Kann ich auch nur empfehlen
Was auch echt gerade
Für mich
Sehr gut ist, wegen hier
Krankheitsgeschichten, ja
Dass ich da nicht so viel Stress habe
Das ist gut, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich 100%
Wahrscheinlich würde ich 100% gar nicht hinkriegen
Gerade
Aber
So ist das top
Wollen wir mal kurz Tee trinken
Ja, das ist halt echt der Witz, ne
Weil letztendlich sind genau das die Leute
Die den Laden hier am Laufen halten
Und das die gerade
Ich muss jetzt auch mal sagen, dass das jetzt gerade auch wieder, besonders bei den Leuten, die ganz gut verdienen, nochmal extra zu lang ist auch krass.
Ich meine, was ich an Abgaben und Steuern bezahle, ist echt nicht mehr normal.
Und ich kriege ja auch immer weniger für.
Zumal, und das wird bei der Sachen vergessen, dass Leute, die auf dem Papier ganz gut verdienen, nicht mehr wirklich krass gut verdienen.
Also so wie sich das alles verteuert hat die letzten Jahre
Keine Ahnung
Wenn einer 100k plus im Jahr verdient hat
Vor 10 Jahren
Da kannst du sagen, okay, der verdient aber echt ordentlich viel
Wenn jetzt einer 100k verdient im Jahr
Wenn man das alles abzieht
Was der abgeben muss
Ja dann verdient er sicherlich immer noch
Weit weit weit besser als der Durchschnitt
Aber man kann jetzt nicht so tun
Als kann er in Saus und Braus leben
Oder sowas
Also es ist echt für den Arsch
Deswegen finde ich es auch
Ähm
Immer schwer vermittelbar
Deswegen finde ich es auch immer schwer vermittelbar
Wenn man
Ich hab letztens
Bei Spiegel TV
Hab ich
Ähm
Bericht gesehen
Oder gelesen besser gesagt
Also in Zusammenfassung gelesen.
Von jemand, der, ich glaube, aus Syrien geflüchtet ist, irgendwie zwei Frauen mitgebracht hat, drei Kinder oder so am Start hat und dem sein Ziel quasi ist, noch neun Kinder zu bekommen und noch zwei neue Frauen.
Und er würde ja am liebsten daheim bleiben und nicht arbeiten, dass er sich um die Kinder kümmern kann.
Ja, das sind sicherlich nicht extrem viele Leute, aber ich finde es halt echt schwer vermittelbar, wenn man dann solche Extrembeispiele sieht und gleichzeitig dann erzählt wird, wir müssen alle den Gürtel enger schnallen und uns alle mehr anstrengen.
Das ist halt enorm schwer vermittelbar.
Ja.
Das weiß man ja nicht, was die Kinder machen.
Letztens hat einer im Stream auch gesagt, die Kinder würden unsere Rente dann bezahlen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wenn die in so einem Haushalt aufgewachsen sind, ob das stimmt.
Keine Ahnung.
Wäre ja zu hoffen.
Naja, aber das Thema triggert mich auch.
Deswegen.
Deswegen, ja, die Diskussion will ich jetzt gar nicht aufmachen.
Das gibt es schon.
Aber ich finde, das wiegt dann trotzdem nochmal schwerer.
Weil es ja jemand ist, der noch nie was einbezahlt hat.
Noch nie was gearbeitet hat.
Gut, ich meine, das gibt es bei Deutschen sicherlich auch.
Aber trotzdem.
Das würde mich bei Deutschen im Prinzip auch ähnlich triggern.
Ja, wenn ich das hören würde. Es kann halt nicht sein, dass wir erzählt kriegen, du musst mehr arbeiten, weniger Krankheitstage haben, Gürtel enger schnallen und dann hast du Leute, die irgendwie 8k oder so im Monat überwiesen bekommen fürs nix machen. Außer fürs Kinderzeugen.
Und dann sehe ich meine Arbeitskollegen teilweise mit zwei, drei Kindern, die, obwohl die wirklich gut verdienen, am Ende des Monats so gut wie nichts übrig haben, weil es halt nicht gerade billig ist.
Aber das Thema triggert mich auch
Ich ignoriere die meisten
News in der Richtung
Mittlerweile, weil es mich nur noch abfuckt
So, jetzt machen wir mal Update und Reboot.
Äh
Nee
Ich glaub das ist
Zu
Wie soll ich sagen
Das nervt zu viele Leute
Ich will mich auch gar nicht so sehr über das Thema aufregen
Weil mich nervt das auch
Und dann bin ich den ganzen Tag wieder schlecht drauf
So in 10k Schritten
Okay wenn ich mich abgeregt hab können wir das machen
Oh, was jetzt? Was haben meine... Was hat der Kernel für Probleme? Gerade an den Kernel-Header für Schmerzen?
Mittlerweile nutzt doch auch jeder CacheOS
Also ich benutze aktuell
Also betriebssystemmäßig
Habe ich, lass mal überlegen
Was benutze ich regelmäßig
Okay, ja
Windows immer noch
Windows
CacheOS
Nargisches Arsch Linux
Wenn ich nicht streame, habe ich ja immer noch ganz normal meine VM.
Magisches Arschlinux.
Arschlinux, vor allem Arschlinux meine ich.
iOS, Android.
Debian.
Ja, und gezwungenermaßen, und gezwungenermaßen ganz viel Red Hat.
da komme ich nicht drum herum red hat zu benutzen weil auf der arbeit ist nur
red hat angesagt es gibt wir haben ein paar selbstgebaute ubuntu container
images aber die vms und ansonsten ist das meiste red hat und sogar richtig
lizenziertes Red Hat, ja?
Jetzt nicht irgendwie Rocky Linux oder sowas.
So richtig echtes Red Hat.
So richtig verstehen tu ich das
ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Warum wir da so viel Geld ausgeben? Ja, es ist echt so.
Es ist wirklich echt so.
So hundertprozentig
verstehen, warum wir da so viel Geld ausgeben,
tu ich nicht.
Man könnte ja zumindest sagen,
man macht die Testumgebung alles mit Rocky Linux und muss da keine Lizenzgebühren für bezahlen.
Wobei wir wahrscheinlich irgendwelche großen Lizenzpackages gekauft haben.
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie das läuft.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, wir könnten ordentlich Geld sparen,
wenn wir nicht alles offizielles Red Hat benutzen würden.
Wie ist der Red Hat Support?
Mehr oder weniger genauso useless wie der Google und Microsoft Support.
Oder der Oracle Support.
Das heißt, bei allen Support, also bei allen Herstellern, bei allen größeren Herstellern, wo du Support gekauft hast, ist es mehr oder weniger gleich.
Die haben ja so garantierte Antwortzeiten, wo die quasi auf ein neues Support-Ticket reagieren müssen.
Dementsprechend ist die Antwort halt mittlerweile, und früher auch schon, aber mittlerweile ist sie wahrscheinlich noch mit AI erstellt.
Die erste Antwort, ich könnte immer mal in den Chat schreiben, ob ihr das kennt.
Ja, wenn ihr, egal, jetzt ist Red Hat, Canonical, Microsoft, Google, ist egal, wenn ihr ein Ticket aufmacht oder wenn ihr schon mal ein Ticket aufgemacht habt.
Die erste Antwort ist eigentlich immer, das was du geschrieben hast, nochmal mit anderen Worten wiedergegeben.
Ja, du schreibst so nach dem Motto, ey, guck mal, wir haben hier vermutlich einen Bug, Memory Leak in dem und dem Package.
das crasht immer nach 24 Stunden, wenn das so und so viele Requests kriegt.
Ich habe mir jetzt irgendwas ausgedacht, ja.
Und wir vermuten, dass das ab dieser Patch-Version auftritt, bla bla bla.
Und dann kommt als erste Antwort, da kommt als erste Antwort,
ah, sie haben wohl ein Problem mit dem Package XY,
bei dem ein Out-of-Memory-Fehler alle 24 Stunden auftritt.
Haben Sie schon die Knowledge Base über Out of Memory gelesen?
Erhöhen Sie testweise den Arbeitsspeicher der Maschine mit freundlichen Grüßen.
Wenn das Ihr Problem gelöst hat, dann schließen wir das Ticket.
Das sind so die ersten Antworten immer.
Die sind komplett useless.
Und das ist nur, dass die ihre SLA-Sachen halt einhalten, weil die halt geschrieben haben, wir antworten innerhalb von, keine Ahnung, 8, 12, 24 Stunden auf das Ticket.
Ihr auch? Wir auch. Wir haben auch Copilot jetzt.
Wir haben auch jetzt Co-Pilot
M365 Co-Pilot
Wie das jetzt ja neuerdings heißt
Genau
M365 Co-Pilot
Weil Microsoft
Laufend ihren ganzen Krempel irgendwie umbenennt
Es gibt doch so ein lustiges Chart
Co-Pilot Chart
Wo
Wo drinnen steht
hier.
Wo ist der?
Darf ich?
Oh Gott, Reddit!
Reddit!
Ich will das Bild aufmachen.
Ich will das Bild aufmachen, Reddit.
Ich will nicht eure scheiß Seite sehen.
Ich will das Bild im Fullscreen.
Warum suckt Reddit eigentlich so krass?
Okay, save image.
Download.
Da mach ich das eben so auf.
Mit Chrome!
Oh, bam, das habt ihr jetzt davon.
Excellent.
So, das wollte ich...
Oh, kein W.
Das wollte ich eigentlich gerade zeigen.
Da gibt es ja diese Übersicht.
Was es alles bei Microsoft gibt.
Also alle Co-Pilot-Produkte sind das.
Man muss sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Gibt es irgendjemand auf dieser Welt, auch bei Microsoft selbst, der da noch durchblickt?
Ich kann es mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen.
Old Reddit soll man jetzt nur nicht mit Login nutzen dürfen.
Wie jetzt? Man braucht jetzt ein Login für Old Reddit?
Sind die komplett dumm, oder was?
Warum ist das removed bei Moderator?
Hier ist es noch da.
Die Grafik ist von März. Meinst du, die ist wirklich noch aktuell?
Ne, wahrscheinlich nicht. Da kamen wahrscheinlich noch 20 neue Co-Pilot-Sachen dabei.
Aber guckt euch diesen krassen Overlap an.
Microsoft 365 Copilot, Copilot Studio, Copilot Chat, Copilot for Sales, Copilot App, Copilot for reicht gar nicht mehr.
Copilot for SMB, Copilot for Windows, Microsoft Copilot, Copilot Pro, Azure Copilot.
wir sind bisher deine erfahrung mit copilot also
ich habe glaube ich von den ganzen ki sachen mittlerweile copilot am wenigsten
benutzt aber wir haben seit ungefähr einer woche auf der arbeit
auch microsoft 365 copilot und ich ziehe das unseren anderen ki chat lösungen vor
die wir auf der arbeit haben das liegt aber auch daran die anderen sind etwas outdated die haben
sich von google und die haben sich von microsoft quasi so einen privaten ford von ihren kais
gekauft das bieten die an also kannst du kannst quasi privaten copilot laufen privaten chat gpt
laufen lassen und ein privates gemini laufen lassen das problem ist dass die das entweder
nur anbieten in der veralteten version oder wie es nur in der veralteten version gekauft haben
Bei Google Models haben wir Gemini 2.5 Pro. Das ist halt von März 2025. Und Leute, im AI-Game ist März 2025, da zu sagen, das wäre Steinzeit, ist noch zu viel. Das ist quasi so erste Lebensform im Meer.
Zeit.
So alt ist das.
Eineinhalb Jahre.
Das ist nicht mal Antik. Das stimmt nicht.
Antik ist außerdem Nachsteinzeit.
Das ist, wie gesagt, das ist so
erste Lebensform im Meer alt.
So alt ist das.
Das kannst du halt knicken. Und dann haben wir noch
GPT 5.1 oder so. Das ist in Vietnam
total outdated. Deswegen bin ich eigentlich ganz froh,
dass wir jetzt
365 Co-Pilot haben.
Und ich habe das die letzte Woche über schon,
vielleicht sind es noch zwei Wochen, öfters mal benutzt
und die Antworten
haben mir besser gefallen als die
von Gemini25.
Ja, aber das ist halt hier
der komplette Witz.
Microsoft da wieder treibt.
Das hier ist auch nicht schlecht.
So viel
Co-Pilot-Shit.
Und das Lustige ist ja,
wenn du dir mal anguckst,
für das das Microsoft so krass viel
auf AI macht,
Wenn du dir mal anguckst, was ist für AI-Funktionen
Also
Ich will dir jetzt nicht dazu anhalten
Mehr AI-Funktionen in Windows einzubauen
Aber wenn man sich mal die AI-Funktionen
Anguckt, die in Windows drin sind
So Sachen wie diese Paint Copilot-Geschichte
Und in Notepad
Das ist halt einfach
Billig, ja
Richtig billig, keine Ahnung was das ist
Also wenn die sowas einbauen, dann könnten sie auch was gescheites machen
Aber das ist einfach nur Rotz
Aber ich habe euch ja schon erzählt, woran ich, also warum ich denke, weshalb es diese
ganzen Funktionen gibt.
Das ist, weil man so Karriere machen kann bei Microsoft.
Da habe ich mir schon öfters drüber ausgelassen.
Wenn euer Chef sagt, meine Vision ist XYZ.
Wie machst du eher Karriere?
Wenn du ihm immer mal wieder beibringst, dass seine Vision eigentlich nicht gewollt ist.
Oder indem du voll ins gleiche Horn bläst und sagst, jawohl, beste Vision ever, wir bauen das jetzt überall ein.
Natürlich, indem du sagst, beste Vision ever und wir bauen das überall ein.
Und dementsprechend, deswegen haben wir in Notepad und Paint und Gedöns unter Windows Copilot, weil das für die Karriere der Leute gut ist.
Dynamics kenne ich nicht, hatte ich noch nie was mit zu tun
und ehrlich gesagt
ich will damit auch nichts zu tun haben
ich benutze eigentlich so gut wie
so wenig wie möglich
irgendwelche Microsoft Programme
ich benutze kein Office
außer es geht nicht anders
das einzige was ich halt verwende ist
gezwungenermaßen Windows
und ansonsten
auf der Arbeit ist halt viel Microsoft-Zeug,
aber letztendlich, was ich auf der Arbeit
zu 90% verwende, ist
ich log mich ein
und dann Linux Terminal
im Fullscreen, also ich log mich unter Windows ein,
dann log ich mich
auf meine Linux-Kiste von dort aus ein,
Fullscreen Terminal, fertig.
Reicht.
Für den ganzen Tag.
Windows Z...
Mach es doch mit Updates regelmäßig.
Du hast vielleicht Glück gehabt
in letzter Zeit, dass du das nicht abbekommen hast.
Aber gibt es doch regelmäßig.
Regelmäßig machen Updates
Sachen kaputt.
Das war Microsoft Dynamics.
Meinst du das hier?
Der Boss ist back
Seven
Okay, wie sieht das aus?
Da gibt es doch nicht mal ein Bild von
Das da?
Hä, das ist ein Kanban-Board
Oder sowas
Es ist bestimmt Vibe-Coded
Das hat Microsoft bestimmt
Vibe-Coded
Das sieht so typisch
Vibe-Coded aus
Oh Moment, vielleicht soll ich mal
Eine andere Musik anmachen, die haben wir jetzt schon
Fünften Mal in Schleife laufen
Komm, wir machen wieder Mario Kart.
Ich mag die Mario Kart Musik.
Exzellent.
Das da, der sieht ja richtig eklig aus.
UI. Guck mal das mal an.
Äh.
Also K... Äh, was ist das?
Ey, das sieht ja overloaded
as fuck aus.
Und was soll das jetzt bedeuten eigentlich, was ich
hier sehe? Was ist das?
Da würde ich
Also wenn ich hier schon wieder
Scrollbalken in Scrollbalken sehe
Kriege ich schon Anfälle
Ne, hör mal bloß auf
Hör mal bloß auf
WTF
Kommt das noch von Windows 8?
Da sind zu viele Kacheln
Okay, weg.
Moin Max, guck dir mal Arm von MyDeals an.
Ist MyDeals nicht so eine Webseite?
Moment, haben die auf YouTube auch was?
Achso, die haben auch ein YouTube-Video.
Meine Filme digitalisieren sich jetzt von selber.
Automatic Ripping Machine.
Ah, Linux-Distribution, verstehe.
Ach Leute, wollten wir uns nicht schon die ganze Zeit mal dieses FireShip-Video angucken,
wo er über den SQLite Rewrite in Rust erzählt,
was wir uns nicht angucken konnten, weil er da irgendeinen Dildo oder so drin hatte
und YouTube das Video deswegen gesperrt hat.
Mittlerweile gibt es das Video aber ohne Dildo drin.
Und jetzt kann man sich das wohl angucken, ohne 18 zu sein.
Ja, das wollten wir uns zwar schon die ganze Zeit angucken.
Weil ich ja mal wieder,
engst dir nicht wie ich bin, was Rust Rewrites angeht,
nicht den Sinn davon verstanden habe,
warum Esculight in Rust
rewritet werden muss.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet?
Ich muss immer noch
rebooten. Wir haben noch nicht rebooted.
Hammern!
Ach, guck mal!
Das ist jetzt neu! Die zeigen jetzt an,
wann es zuletzt geupdatet wurde.
Ist das vielleicht als Schutz gedacht,
vor irgendwelchen Supply Chain Angriffen oder so?
Dass du erstmal
drei Tage warten kannst,
bevor du updatest?
Ich trau mich nicht mal, Arch User Repos
zu updaten, Leute.
Ich hab Schiss.
Dass ich gehackermanned werde.
Aber hier die Jetbrain Sachen
müssen wir updaten.
Oh, es laggt.
Es laggt.
Guck mal meine CPU-Auslastung.
CPU-Auslastung komplett auf 100%.
100% CPU-Auslastung.
Wegen Jetbrain-Updates.
Achtung Toss.
Moment, das gucke ich mir nicht on-stream an.
Das kenn ich
Das Emote hab ich auch mal gesehen
Ich glaub bei Simply
Der Mario 64 Speedrunner
Das wurde dann aber irgendwann
Entfernt
So
Warten wir mal bis die Updates durch sind
Und dann schauen wir mal was auf GitHub so trendet
Wobei ich muss noch rebooten
Wichtig
Wobei ich könnte auch
Einfach drauf verzichten zu rebooten
Weil dann muss ich wieder alles neu aufmachen
Ich hab ne Lizenz
Aber sind auch viele IDEs mittlerweile kostenlos
Also guck mal
Gehen wir mal durch
Also ich habe eine Lizenz, die habe ich seit Jahren schon.
Ich habe so eine All-Desktop-Package.
Das kostet irgendwie 170 Euro oder so im Jahr.
Also gehen wir mal durch.
Mittlerweile ist nämlich sehr viel kostenlos.
Ich glaube, es ist aber nur kostenlos für Non-Commercial-Use oder?
Fragezeichen? Ich weiß nicht genau.
Also lasst uns hier mal durchgehen.
Rustrover ist, glaube ich, auch kostenlos benutzbar.
IntelliJ ist schon sehr lange kostenlos nutzbar
Also IntelliJ ist quasi schon seit Anfang an
Mehr oder weniger kostenlos nutzbar
Es gibt davon
Es gibt davon eine
Ne, gibt es auch nicht mehr
Es gibt nur noch eine IntelliJ Variante
Es gab mal IntelliJ Pro oder sowas
Also IntelliJ ist kostenlos nutzbar
Schon ganz lange
Goland glaube ich nicht
Ich glaube Goland kostet tatsächlich was
Das gibt es keine kostenlose Version von
Pycharm gibt es
Pycharm ist kostenlos
Sea Lion
Nicht sicher
Rider mittlerweile auch kostenlos
Bei den anderen ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung
Aber das meiste kannst du da mittlerweile kostenlos
Von Non-Commercial-Use benutzen
IntelliJ ist raus aus dem kostenlos?
Nee, oder?
IntelliJ war doch schon länger kostenlos
Wirklich?
IntelliJ war doch schon länger kostenlos als alle anderen
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee
Das kann ich
Da würden die sich ja selbst
Da würden die sich ja selbst ein bisschen
Absägen
Wenn IntelliJ da rausfliegen würde, oder?
Ne, gibt es immer noch hier.
Kannst du immer noch einfach runterladen bei denen auf der Webseite.
Karte ist mit Ultimate-Wärmung.
Ja, wie ein Jux.
Wird hier nicht aufgelistet?
Ja, weil du mit IntelliJ wahrscheinlich auch Commercial machen darfst.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Weil, wie gesagt, IntelliJ ist super weit verbreitet.
Wenn die Updates sein Stream-Content sind...
Ja, ich hab ja auch.
Ich hab ja auch ein...
Unabhängig davon, ob das jetzt so ist oder nicht.
Ich hab ja auch ein Abo.
So, okay.
Ich glaube, die Updates sind fertig, hä?
Okay.
Ich werde nicht rebooten, Leute.
Ich bin zu faul, das wieder alles zu starten.
Call Champ.
Zeig mal, was hier bei Non-Commercial-Use steht.
Wie mich das mit dem Wallet abfuckt.
Ja, ich glaube, IntelliJ steht da nicht drauf, weil IntelliJ darf commercial genutzt werden.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Wow, was haben sie hier auch?
Da haben sich die Webdesign so aber ausgelassen hier.
SeaLine, Rider, Webster...
Okay, GoLand, wie ich gesagt habe, ist nicht dabei.
Aber es ist top, ne?
Also ich guck mal.
Du kannst Rust.net...
Ruby.
Wusste gar nicht, dass das auch kostenlos ist.
Und C...
Beziehungsweise C++.
Das ist, finde ich, auch die beste C++-Idee.
C++ ist der größte Rotz ever.
Und mit dieser IDE ist es immer noch der größte Rotz ever.
Aber man kann es irgendwie handeln.
Oh, es gibt sogar ReSharper.
Das gab es früher für Visual Studio.
Das war dafür bekannt, ganz viel RAM zu fressen.
Data Grip habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Eine IDE für SQL und NoSQL Datenbanken.
Moment, warum brauche ich eine IDE für Datenbanken?
Das muss mir jetzt mal einer erklären.
Hat man dann Autocomplete für SQL oder was?
Das habe ich noch nie verwendet.
data club ist geil gerade für große datenbank und geodaten
snap nein danke habe ich noch nie ausprobiert
kreinern
dann lasst uns doch mal bevor wir bevor wir in github trends gucken lasst uns doch mal
weil ich werde das sonst garantiert wieder vergessen lass uns doch mal das video gucken
zum sql light oder von sqlite sagen es vielleicht in rust was fire ship dazu zu sagen hat
Und warum und weshalb und was da dran so gut ist, zeig mal her.
Oh, Moment, Moment. Chat, Chat, Sekunde.
Muss ich erstmal checken.
Die Lautstärke ist gut, oder? Jetzt ist es okay.
Machen wir nochmal.
zu verändern, als wir es wussten, aber das größte Problem war, dass die App, die HIP
gebaut hatte, auf einer SQL-Database basierte und je nachdem, wann der Database-Server runterging,
seine App auch.
Also hat er sich eine...
Moment, das heißt, die Raketenabwehr von amerikanischen Schiffen ging nicht, wenn die
Netzwerkverbindung zum Datenbank-Server unterbrochen war?
Das wirkt mir aber hart wie ein Single Point of Failure, oder?
Das stimmt wohl, SQLite ist überall.
Das vergisst man oftmals.
Ich glaube, jede Android-Anwendung hat eine eigene SQLite-Datenbank.
Standardmäßig.
Also, die gibt es millionenfach.
Wenn nicht milliardenfach.
Guck mal, sogar...
Guck mal, sogar der Mars-Rover hat eine SQLite-Datenbank.
Solange sie es nicht per Rust-Vibe coden.
Okay, das müssen Pfeifert-Leute sein.
Hat er hier früher das gezeigt, warum YouTube das Video gesperrt hat?
Hier war früher das Tränen, warum YouTube das Video gesperrt hatte, oder?
Stimmt. Das ist tatsächlich ein Problem gewesen, immer in SQLite.
wobei man sich da halt fragen muss
für das
wo SQLite in der Regel verwendet wird
ist das wirklich so ein großer
Drawback
wobei wir haben im Stream schon
Web-Anwendungs-Backends
gebastelt mit SQLite
Datenbank
da wäre das über kurz oder lang
wahrscheinlich echt
der Flaschenhals geworden
also wenn das was gewesen wäre
was ich released hätte
und was dann Leute benutzt hätten.
Oh, das ist nice.
das ist das ist cool also sprich du hast jetzt zwei sachen
du kannst quasi so ich sag mal multi trend mit multiple writers und du kannst
aber auch es operations machen also sprich du sagst der datenbank mach mal x
y und in der zeit wo die datenbank rüttelt geht der control flow zurück und
du kannst was anderes machen das ist natürlich das ist natürlich
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Nochmal.
Vektor-Types? Das braucht man für LLM-Gedöns, oder?
und weißt du was die auch im zweifelsfall machen müssen
habt ihr habt ihr die probleme mitbekommen die ubuntu hat mit dem rastri reit von den
Core-Utils.
Erst vor ein paar Tagen gab es wieder eine News,
dass die aktuelle Ubuntu-Version,
also die
kommende Ubuntu-Version,
kaputt ist,
weil Bug in Core-Utils
die müssen
auch dafür sorgen,
wenn sie
ein Drop-in-Replacement sein wollen,
die müssen auch
komisches Verhalten von
SQLite nachbauen.
Also wenn SQLite irgendwas macht, wo du dich fragst, äh, was ist das denn? Das ist ja unsinnig. Da müssen die das nachbauen, weil es irgendjemanden gibt, der darauf setzt, dass dieses Verhalten so ist, wie es ist, damit seine Anwendung funktioniert. Nur dann sind sie richtiges Drop-in-Replacement. So wie das eben der Rust-Rewrite von den Core-Utils nicht ist.
... und es in den Netzwerk verwenden.
Aber die Never-Lose-Data-Parte ist schwieriger.
Um da zu kommen, benutzt Turso eine interessante Teststrategie,
die Deterministische Simulation heißt.
Sie machen die ganze Datenbank in einem simulierten Universum
und spielen Gott mit Zeit, der Netzwerk und dem Disk.
Dann verursachen sie Fehler wie Powerlose, Mitte-Richt,
eine korruptierte Seite oder ein Disk,
das darüber liegt, ob es deine Daten gespeichert hat.
Und dann spielen sie den gleichen Szenario
aus dem selben randomen Seed, bis sie den Bug abschneiden.
Und weil TURSO tatsächlich open source ist, kann jeder, wie man traditionell würde, zahlen.
Also ist das Überwinden der am besten vertrauten Datenbank auf der Erde eigentlich eine gute Idee?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber man wird nur als Idiot gesehen, bis es funktioniert.
Und sprichst du von Ideen, die dumm klingen, bis sie funktionieren, was, wenn dein AI-Koding-Agent dein Geld nicht auf Feuer setzt?
Und deshalb musst du wissen, was Jetbrains angeht.
Okay. Setout-Modus. Klingt doch gar nicht so schlecht eigentlich, oder? TURSO.
Nee, Turso.
Turso.
Hat auch schon ordentlich viele
Stars gefarmt auf GitHub.
Nee, ich installiere
mir hier auf dem
kein Sponsor-Blog.
Denk mal, wenn ich mir schon
andere Videos hier angucke,
Content von anderen Leuten,
dann darf auch durchaus mal das ein oder andere
Sponsoring aufploppen.
Oh, das ist auch
FyFet, was Neues. Da habe ich letztens auch
ein Video gesehen drüber,
über diese neue Asynchron IOS
Support in Linux, IOU Ring.
Kriege ich aber nicht mal zusammen
aus dem Kopf. Das ist aber auch irgendein
FyFet-Ding, wo du
auch sagen kannst,
mach mal IOU
und du kannst in der Zwischenzeit was anderes
machen, bis es fertig ist.
so dann schauen wir doch mal was trendet diese woche auf github
by the way wie kommt man jetzt eigentlich zu den trending zu der
trending seite offiziell so
i owe you ring ist gefühlt 70 prozent der vulnerabilities verantwortlich
schon sein aber trotzdem nice
Ja, günstigen Speicher-Sellout mache ich später.
Aber ihr könnt natürlich jetzt auch mal Ausrufezeichen Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen Seagate oder Ausrufezeichen Alternate im Chat machen.
Da findet ihr einen Link zum Wubblos Alternate Shop.
Da könnt ihr günstig Ukraine Nasses und günstig Festplatten kaufen.
Überpreise die nur über meinen Link-Geld.
Caveman.
Okay, AI.
Verstehe.
Codex Plugin.
Okay, wir skippen mal wieder KI.
So, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
AI, weiß ich nicht, AI, AI, AI, Immich kennen wir schon, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung was das sein soll, AI, AI, AI, AI, nice.
Okay, also was haben wir hier?
A beautiful, powerful, self-hosted ROM-Manager
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment
ROM-Manager
Also für runtergeladene Linux-Distributionen, oder wie?
Ja
Okay, offensichtlich für selbst runtergeladene Linux-Distributionen
Wie man sieht, alles Linux-Distributionen.
Cloud-Ordner spotted.
Ah ja.
Da wurde wahrscheinlich ordentlich, ordentlich Vibe-Coded.
Wollen wir mal checken, ob das irgendwie Vibe-Coded aussieht.
Python ist es. Eine Python-Anwendung.
Gucken wir mal. Keine Ahnung.
Endpoints.
Ich weiß.
Ich finde, sieht gar nicht so krass
Vibe-Coded aus.
Für Ultra-Vibe-Coded
sind zu wenig Comments drin.
Zumindest nicht Hardcore-Vibe-Coded.
Hat er wahrscheinlich entfernt. Vielleicht.
Vielleicht hat er dem auch gesagt,
don't use comments oder so.
Ja, kann schon sein.
Es ist aber immer schwierig,
auf den ersten Blick zu... So, was ist das hier?
Was die Katze macht, die war heute Morgen schon wieder da
und hat sich füttern lassen.
So, was soll das jetzt?
Ah, ja, ja.
Was soll das sein?
Wie übersetzt man den...
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie man ein Firefox
eine Webseite übersetzt.
Bin ich zu dumm für...
Wir machen jetzt einfach...
Zack.
Translate page to English.
Lyrics reimagined.
Reimagined. A new horizon for lyrics and music.
Okay.
Das ist für die ganzen Weebs unter uns.
Irgendwelche Anime-Song-Lyrics oder was.
Online-Music-Player.
Immersive-Lyrics-Playback.
NetEase-Cloud.
Aha.
AI-Generated-Color-Themes.
Guck mal, hier gibt's...
Wie?
Ah, ja, ja!
Gut.
Ein Lyrics Manager.
Max, hast du Vorschläge für die mündliche IHK-Prüfung?
Ja, einen
So spontan
Vorher üben
Aber das hättest du wahrscheinlich
eh gemacht, oder?
Üb das einfach vorher
ein paar Mal, dass du von der Zeit her hinkommst
dass du genau weißt
was du sagen willst
beziehungsweise in welcher Reihenfolge
was kommt, weil wenn du aufgeregt
bist, das ist immer so
Aufregung und Denken
verträgt sich nicht gut zusammen.
Und gerade am Anfang reinkommen
ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Deswegen gerade das Intro gut üben
und dann geht es meistens wie auf Schienen weiter.
Ja, das ist normal.
Wie gesagt, das Intro üben
ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt,
damit du reinkommst, weil du bist aufgeregt,
deswegen kannst du nicht richtig denken.
Und wenn du aber das Intro gemacht hast,
dann musst du nicht mal denken, dann kommst du in den Flow
automatisch rein.
Ich würde es auf jeden Fall üben. Also mit üben meine ich wirklich das auch ein paar Mal halten. Und was durchaus auch sinnig ist, dass du ein bisschen Druck dabei hast, du kannst das den einen oder anderen Arbeitskollegen auch mal vortragen.
Weil dann ist immer ein bisschen mehr Anspannung
Wie wenn man das daheim für sich allein macht
Oder seiner Mutter zeigt oder so
Das ist dann mit ein bisschen mehr Anspannung verbunden
Das ist nicht schlecht
Halt das am besten mal
Eins, zweimal noch vor ein paar Arbeitskollegen
Das ist morgen geplant
Ja dann, safe
Und du musst halt Ahnung davon haben, was du gemacht hast
Aber dann bist du safe
Das passt schon
Wenn du das gemacht hast
Sogar auf der, wann hast du Abschlussprüfung?
Mittwoch.
Ja, das ist doch jetzt genau der richtige Zeitpunkt.
Das kriegst du schon hin.
Also wenn du das sogar noch vor den Arbeitskollegen dann gehalten hast, dann bist du safe.
Wir sehen, das ist kein Ding.
Das ist dann...
Am Ende wirst du sagen, das war...
Genau, das ist ja das, was ich meine.
Aber vor Leuten, wo man auch ein bisschen Anspannung verspürt.
Aber das Wichtigste ist, dass du dein Intro und die erste Folie quasi gut hinkriegst.
Oder halt gut im Kopf hast.
Weil sobald du das Intro durch hast, geht das wie auf Schienen, so eine Presentation.
Dann fällt dir alles wieder ein.
Die Prosa Print Support App.
Ne, die mache ich jetzt nicht auf.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Was trendet denn Amazon?
Dann schauen wir jetzt mal, was trendet denn in Go?
Vielleicht ist da irgendwas Spannendes dabei.
Memos.
Self-House, the note-taking-tool.
Ja, davon gibt es ja auch 30 Milliarden Dinger.
Das haben wir uns aber auch schon mal angeguckt.
Guckst du sich sonst Weekly Trends ab?
Ach!
Doch, ich gucke immer Weekly Trends.
Das habe ich bloß nicht mitgekriegt.
Brain-Dead, Alter.
Was trendet in Hubi?
Oh man, das muss ich mal aufschreiben.
Das gucken wir gleich, was in Ruby trendet.
Also, AI, AI, AI.
Das haben wir uns, glaube ich, schon mal angeguckt.
Und da war ich komplett verwirrt, was das eigentlich sein soll.
Du kannst irgendwie...
Genau, du kannst irgendwie aus Videos 3D-Sachen oder so erstellen.
Ganz abgedrehter Shit, ey.
Echt mega krass, oder?
AI?
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Maven.
Keck Wade, Alter.
Umtrendet das denn?
AI, AI, AI.
Geil.
Das hat sich ja richtig gelohnt.
Das hat sich richtig gelohnt, das Weekly anzugucken.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Was trendet denn in Ruby?
Rails.
Zurecht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich finde Rails ist immer noch ein super Webframework.
Ich habe seit Jahren nichts mehr mitgemacht, aber immer wenn ich was mitgemacht habe früher, hat es Spaß gemacht.
Wir sind mittlerweile schon bei Rails 8.1.3.
Ruby ist auch einfach eine schicke Sprache, muss man mal sagen.
Max, hast du dir schon .NET 11 angeschaut?
Äh.
Nee, kommt das nicht erst im November oder so?
Da gibt es jetzt .NET 11, da gibt es jetzt endlich Union Types, gell?
Das habe ich glaube ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen
Komm wir können uns das gleich angucken
What's new
Würdest du dann
Vorschlagen Rails oder React zum Lernen
Moment Moment Moment
Das sind zwei komplett
Unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe
Rails ist für Web Anwendung
Backends
Du kannst damit auch klassische
Serverseite gerenderte Frontends machen
Aber das ist ja total out mittlerweile
Wobei ich das nicht weiß, wie gut Rails für so halb dynamische Sachen, keine Ahnung.
Aber Rails ist erstmal hauptsächlich ein Backend für Web-Anwendungen.
Und React ist Frontend im Browser für Web-Anwendungen.
Sind zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Ich würde aber heutzutage auch nicht empfehlen, Rails zu lernen.
Gar nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, seit Rails nicht mehr so verbreitet ist, ist Ruby auf dem absteigenden Ast.
und Rails auch.
Ich würde gar nicht Ruby und gar nicht Rails lernen.
Nee, Ruby ist die Programmiersprache.
Ruby und Rails ist das Webframework.
Okay.
Oh, den habe ich noch nie verwendet.
also die react kann man definitiv lernen react ist das meistverbreitete web
frontend überhaupt also frontend framework überhaupt mein persönlicher
favorit ist das welt kit aber react ist wenn wir anguckt was da so verbreitet ist
im business enterprise umfeld ist react falls ihr es nicht wusstet
Microsoft 365, Office, hier dieser Krempel da.
Word, zack, weiß nicht, braucht da mal ein Bild von.
Hier, das da.
Das im Browser.
Browser.
Das Office im Browser.
Wo es irgendwie erstaunlich wenige Screenshots anscheinend von gibt.
Aber das ist React.
Also Office 365 im Browser ist eine React-Anwendung.
Ach, Odin Project ist nicht die Odin Programming Language.
What?
Dann habe ich absolut keine Ahnung, was Odin Project ist.
Your career in...
Your career in Web Development starts here.
All path.
Fullstack Ruby on Rails.
Ganz ehrlich...
Ganz ehrlich würde ich nicht lernen.
Selbst wenn es das da gibt.
Ruby on Rails ist überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt.
Wenn du willst, kann ich dir sagen, was ich lohne für Backend.
Also wo ich der Meinung bin, dass ich es lohne für Backend-Anwendungen.
Also Ruby on Rails würde ich heutzutage nicht mehr lernen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich verschwendete Mühe.
Also mein Lieblings-Web-Backend ist ASP.NET Core auf .NET Basis.
Ich mag ASP.NET Core.
Das ist mein Lieblings-Web-Anwendungs-Backend.
ASP.NET Core.
Go kann auch sehr nice sein.
Wobei Go eher darauf setzt, dass du gar keine Webframeworks verwendest oder alles mit der Standardlibrary machst.
Aber Go ist auch super, gerade wenn es schön schnell starten soll, Single Binaries haben soll, ist Go wunderbar.
Und ansonsten, was wir nicht vergessen dürfen, wahrscheinlich das beliebteste oder eines der beliebtesten Sachen, die es gibt,
sind Sachen auf JavaScript und Python Basis für Backend Sachen.
Bei Python kenne ich mich nicht so aus.
Fast-API oder sowas.
Flask gab es früher noch und solche Geschichten.
Da gab es noch Django, aber ich glaube Django ist auch nicht mehr so beliebt.
Und bei Node.js,
bei Node bzw. bei JavaScript-Backends,
weiß ich ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht, was da so angesagt ist.
Ich habe noch nie JavaScript im Backend verwendet.
Aber ich glaube, dass die JavaScript-Backend-Sachen und die Python-Backend-Sachen mit die verbreitetsten sind, wenn man mal auf GitHub gucken würde.
NestJS, ja NestJS ist auf jeden Fall sehr beliebt, das kenne ich sogar vom Namen her.
Also FastAPI Python ist sehr verbreitet.
Ich persönlich, also mein Lieblings-Backend-Framework ist ASP.NET Core.
Ja, das ist von Microsoft
Aber C Sharp ist eine super
Programmiersprache und das ist auch
Ein sehr komplettes Webframework
Aber kannst du alles machen
Was auch eine Möglichkeit ist
Wenn du Fullstack JavaScript machen willst
So, was gibt es da
Next.js und sowas
Es gibt ja auch komplette Fullstack
JavaScript-Framework, sowas wie SvelteKit zum Beispiel,
da ist Backend und Frontend
quasi integriert in einem.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Das ist auch nicht übel.
Wenn man Web-Anwendungen bauen will.
Für reine, für reine,
so reine API-Backends
jetzt vielleicht eher nicht.
Aber, also da gibt es,
da gibt es sehr viel. Also, da würde ich
an deiner Stelle wirklich nochmal gucken,
weil ich finde, Ruby on Rails
da verschwendest du ein bisschen deine Zeit
letztendlich kann man natürlich sagen, nein, egal was man
gelernt hat, das ist nie verschwendete Zeit
aber ich sag mal, du kannst deine Zeit
wenn du was lernen willst, also wenn du was lernen
möchtest, was halt eben eine gewisse Verbreitung
heutzutage auch hat oder auch
gesucht wird oder ein gewissen
gewissen
gewisses Momentum hat, dann ist es
dann ist es auf jeden Fall nicht Ruby on Rails
dann würde ich mir eher Spring Boot angucken
Java Spring Boot
auch super krass
verbreitet und eigentlich auch nicht schlecht
also bevor du, bevor du Ruby on Rails
lernst, wenn du wirklich was haben willst
was Enterprise mäßig verbreitet ist
und auch taugt
dann Java Spring Boot
Dazu findest du auch 30 Milliarden Tutorials
und YouTube-Videos.
Also Ruby on Rails würde ich nicht mehr machen.
Dann lieber Kotlin Springboot.
Kotlin Springboot kannst du auch machen,
wenn du Framework und
Sprache neu lernen willst.
Aber ich muss sagen,
wir haben ja hier letztens ein bisschen Springboot
und Quarkus, hieß das andere, glaube ich, gemacht.
Ich muss sagen, aktuelles
Java. Ich hab ja Java immer krass geflamed.
Ja. So. Einfach weil's
Spaß macht.
So schlimm fand ich aktuelles Java gar nicht.
Ich glaube schon. Ehrlich gesagt,
keine Ahnung. Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Wobei React Native
und SvelteKit mit V, by the way,
der Ansatz, glaube ich, ein bisschen anders ist.
React Native
ist ja quasi React für Native
Steuerelemente von dem jeweiligen
Betriebssystem, ne? React Native
rendert ja nicht die Sachen
ja nicht selbst, oder?
Also React Native ist nicht ein Webview, der rendert,
sondern React Native
benutzt quasi die Steuerelemente
von iOS und Android zum Beispiel.
Bits Weltkit, glaube ich,
brauchst du noch einen eigenen Webview für.
Rate ich jetzt.
Ich habe beides noch nicht benutzt.
Ist das nicht schon voll lange her?
Weiß nicht, ein halbes Jahr oder so?
Würde ich sagen,
Halbes Jahr.
Irgendwie so.
Aber, um es mal abzuschließen,
letztendlich,
wenn du Bock auf Ruby hast, verschenkt
ist es auch nicht mal so ein bisschen über den Tellerrand zu gucken.
Aber es ist halt null
verbreitet mehr und hat auch
kein Hype und Momentum
so richtig.
Und Ruby selbst kannst du halt auch für nichts mehr
verwenden aktuell.
für neue Sachen.
Also, ich glaube, da kann man
die Zeit besser investieren. Und das sage ich
als riesen Ruby on Rails und vor allem
Ruby-Fan, ja.
Ich habe ja gesagt, meine Top 5
Programmiersprachen, davon auf Platz 1
und 1 und 2
und 2 und 1, teilt sich quasi
C-Sharp und Ruby. Aber
Ruby hat halt ein bisschen
das Nachsehen gehabt
die letzten Jahre.
Okay, guck mal, was mit Ruby so trendet.
Ja, das brauchst du.
Genau, du brauchst, um Mac und iOS Apps zu veröffentlichen, brauchst du zwingend Xcode für das Packagen der App.
Es gibt aber, habe ich gelesen, habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, es gibt wohl mittlerweile Online-Services, die können dir auch eine Mac-App packagen, ohne dass du selbst einen Mac haben musst.
Aber wahrscheinlich brauchst du immer noch einen Apple-Account und sowas.
Und ich glaube, ein Apple-Account reicht auch nicht.
Du brauchst so einen Apple Entwicklungsaccount, der was weiß ich 120 Euro oder so im Jahr kostet und ein Codesigning Zertifikat und Gedöns.
Also Mac und iOS Anwendungen erstellen, das hat tatsächlich eine relativ große Einstiegshürde.
Theoretisch, was du machen kannst ist, vielleicht reicht dir auch eine PWA.
Ja, genau.
Du kannst... PWA.
Je nachdem, was du machen willst, ist eine PWA auch nicht verkehrt.
Mittlerweile gehen ja wohl auch unter iOS Notifications mit PWAs.
Habe ich, glaube ich, gelesen.
Warte mal.
Can I use Notifications?
Man weiß nicht.
Web Notifications.
Can I use...
Safari?
Safari und iOS.
Äh, Partial Support immer noch.
Wie gesagt, Safari ist der Internet Explorer unserer Zeit, ne?
Aber Safari kann das wohl.
Requires Website to add to the home screen.
Ja, das ist okay.
Das ist okay.
Okay.
Haben die PWA Support getroppt?
Nee, oder?
Der PWA Support, also, ich hab mich da die letzten zwei Jahre oder so nicht mehr mit beschäftigt.
Aber das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt habe, wurde der PWA-Support unter iOS immer besser.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja sogar Notification-Support unter iOS.
So.
Dann gucken wir doch mal.
Wir wollten ja gucken, was in Ruby so trendet.
Rails trendet.
Ja, zu Recht.
Doku Seal.
Doku Sign Alternative.
Sonst immer leute treffen sich hier wieder nach jahren im buch los schätzt so muss das sein
doch doch pw as funktionieren auch offline du hättest die dann auf dem homescreen da wird dann
alles gespeichert du musst das in der pw a natürlich supporten dass die offline funktioniert
also nicht irgendwie direkt beim starten call gegen eine webseite machen oder so aber das geht
das geht prinzipiell ich habe es auch noch nicht ausprobiert wie genau aber gehen tut das das weiß
ich geht lab trendet ja geht bleibt ist immer noch in ruby programmiert ruby james ruby james
ist der package manager für für ruby libraries das quasi cargo so was wie cargo in in ruby gibt
das schon viel länger und cargo hat sich sehr stark auch inspirieren lassen von von ruby james
Ruby selbst.
Mastodon.
Das ist Ruby on Rails.
Na gut.
Metasploit.
Ja, das gibt es schon ganz lange.
Das ist in Ruby.
Yubicloud.
Open Source Alternative zu AWS.
Okay.
Self-hosted AWS.
Was zum...
Warum kaufst du das, Alter?
Das ist das übelste Scam-Game.
WTF?
Warum gibst du denen Geld?
Alter, die haben einfach nur krass gescamt.
Ich hab das 2000...
Wann war das? 2012 oder so.
Irgendwann.
Hab ich das gebackt für 200 Euro auf Kickstarter.
und seit dem, seit der ersten
Demo bis heute hat sich nichts,
nichts getan. Das ist so schlecht.
Ich hab, ich hab letztens auf dem
Dark Edge of Camelot
Reddit,
da hat einer ein Mobile,
nee, nicht ein Mobile,
ein Browser-Game,
ein Browser-Game gezeigt, ja.
Ein Browser-Game gezeigt,
was er irgendwie in einem halben Jahr
zusammen gebastelt hat
und das ist besser als Camelot
und Jade.
Das ist wirklich...
Das ist eine Schande,
dass das überhaupt mit Daruk
in Verbindung gebracht wird mittlerweile.
Daruk ist immer noch das beste MMO ever.
Zumindest wenn man
PvP mag.
Wobei es da ja eigentlich RvR heißt.
Beste MMO,
was es je gegeben hat in der Richtung.
Aber Camelot Unchained ist halt
lächerlich.
Nur noch.
Das ist Hyper Deforged. Da ist ja nichts davon drin.
Moment, ich muss gerade mal
just for fun was gucken.
Steam Charts.
Zu Recht, Alter.
Zu Recht.
Moment, es gibt wirklich 123 Leute,
die diesen Scheiß spielen?
Das sind doch die Entwickler selbst, die da eingeloggt sind, oder?
Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
WTF, Mann.
Wie kann man so ein Scam-Crap
unterstützen?
Also ich meine,
nicht Chatke, sondern die Leute,
die dann wirklich das auch noch spielen.
Ich dachte, du übertreibst.
Ja, gut, aber gut, dass ich jetzt mal
aus erster Hand einen kenne,
der das ausprobiert hat.
Also ich habe das nicht auf Steam gekauft.
Ich habe ja Backer-Axes
seit, weiß ich nicht,
elf Jahren oder so.
Aber ich hab's auch nicht mehr gespielt zu Release jetzt.
Also, seh ich nicht ein.
Kommt mir nicht mehr auf die Festplatte drauf, auf die SSD drauf.
Warum ist eine Liste, die Swift Libraries und Ressourcen enthält,
warum ist die in Ruby programmiert?
Warum ist eine Liste überhaupt in Ruby programmiert?
Kann mir das mal irgendeiner erklären?
Ruby!
Das ist eine Liste für Swift und iOS
Resources. Die Liste
ist aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen in Ruby?
What?
Ich sehe hier nicht ein
Ruby-File drin. Was macht
GitHub dafür? Danger-File.
Okay,
das sieht ein bisschen
nach Ruby aus.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Homebrew.
Ah ja, Homebrew ist auch in Ruby
programmiert. MacOS Package
Manager.
Wisst ihr, woran man erkennt, dass
Ruby überhaupt nicht mehr
im Trend ist und ziemlich
oldschool? Wir haben bis jetzt
nicht ein AI-Projekt gesehen
Ruby Trends
Daran erkennt man es. Homebrew ist in Ruby, ja
Ruby SDK for Temporal
was auch immer. Datadog
AP. Ich hoffe, ich kann euch
mal zeigen, dass Ruby eine hübsche Programmiersprache
ist. Lass mal kurz gucken.
Äh, Lib. Ich mach jetzt
einfach mal irgendwas auf, in der Hoffnung.
Ähm,
keine Ahnung, Helper RB.
Okay, das ist sehr minimalistisch, würde ich
sagen. Äh,
keine Ahnung, Cache Context RB.
Ja.
Okay, ich finde, Ruby ist eine sehr hübsche
Programmiersprache.
Diese ganze, diese mit dem ganzen
Ad erinnert ein bisschen an Springboot, ist es aber nicht
Das ist Instanzvariable
Hier, Ad
Das ist quasi sowas wie
Wenn ich das in C Sharp
Wenn ich das oben in der Klasse definiere
So, da kann ich dann überall drauf zugreifen
Ad-User
Aber Ruby ist eine echt hübsche Programmiersprache
Guck mal, mach mal
BeautifulRuby
Code Example.
So, was gibt?
Beautiful Ruby Code.
Okay, bin ich mal gespannt.
Ob das jetzt so beautiful ist?
Ja, das ist...
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
ob das hier besser ist als das hier.
Aber Ruby ist eine wirklich schöne
Programmiersprache.
Oh, jetzt habe ich die
GitHub-Trends irgendwie zugemacht.
Hallo?
Äh.
Okay.
Also.
Next.
Dann gucken wir mal, was in Go trendet.
So die interessanten Sprachen.
No mistakes.
das hatten wir schon terraform hatten wir auch schon netbörse hatten wir auch schon
promisius prometheus trendet auch zurecht top projekt super file file brauchen wir nicht
Proxy, CasaOS haben wir ausprobiert, SACT, Ethereum Implementation, AI, Vulnerability Scanner, Keploi,
was ist das denn? Arbor, das ist eine Container Registry, Telegraph, FZF, FZF haben wir letzte Woche erst, auch super Projekt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es sein soll.
Kubernetes und Hugo trennen.
Hugo ist so ein Static Site Generator.
Okay, lass uns mal kurz angucken.
Was ist Keploi?
Gibt es da ein ordentliches Beispiel für?
Ist ein Developer-Centric
API and Integration Testing Tool
that also
generates tests.
Okay.
Oder auch immer.
Obernett
Obernetters Native Job Queuing
Monkass
Wall of Text
Okay, nix was mich jetzt juckt
Okay, was trendet in
Nein, wir gucken diese Woche nicht C++
Okay, was trendet in C Sharp
ASP.NET Core
Bestes Web
oder bestes Backend-Framework
ever, meiner Meinung nach.
Obwohl es von Microsoft ist.
Und obwohl wahrscheinlich
mittlerweile sogar was drin in Vibe-Coded ist.
Bei Microsoft weißt du ja nie. Beste.
Hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon,
hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon.
Hier nochmal, was für die
Weeps unter uns.
Eine Runde
Osu.
So ein Musik-Rhythmus-Game,
wo die Leute
immer irgendwelche anime lieder anhören und da dann mit der maus auf buttons klicken
eine neue interessante software
ich weiß nicht ich gucke uns das gerade mal an
gleich mal meinen ups gleich mal meine sind dazu geben
Ich krieg Anfälle wegen dieser Wallet-Sache
Das fuckt mich so krass ab
Powerfulness made effortless
Das ist wieder sowas
Wo sie ein schönes Gui davor geklatscht haben
Aber das im Endeffekt wahrscheinlich nix kann
Ist der Stream da auch ne?
Läuft alles noch
Ich glaube das ist etwas, was ich nie verwenden werde.
Okay, ZFS, BTFS, EXT4, RAID.
Die haben sich sehr von MacOS Design inspirieren lassen, oder?
Ja, ich könnte das Wallet unlocken.
Das stimmt dann wäre das weg.
Ah, das kostet doch was.
Free, always free
Tja, weiß nicht, ob das was taucht
Irgendwie gibt mir das so Vibes
Als gefällt es mir nicht
Ich kann nicht sagen, warum
Aber
Ich vibe damit nicht, wie man das glaube ich heute sagt
Ja, also
Mir gefällt es irgendwie.
Irgendwie sagt mir das nichts zu.
.NET selbst trendet.
AI, Rosalind trendet.
Das ist quasi der C-Sharp Compiler.
Was soll denn das sein?
Pac-Man Alternative for Archie,
ist written in SIG,
taucht aber in C-Sharp auf.
Wer hat denn da wieder Vibe-Coded
bei GitHub, Leute?
Wer hat denn da wieder Hard-Vibe-Coded?
Okay, 40% C-Sharp,
56% SIG. Lass mich raten.
Die haben...
Haben die das rewritten?
Von C Sharp
zu SIG oder was?
App Group.
Was soll das sein?
Aha.
Ah.
Okay, das ist sogar mal ein ganz cooles Feature
für die Taskleiste.
Wie erweitert man die denn...
Die Windows Taskleiste
ist eine react app
sammler mensch das sie ist das ist so eklig das ist so eklig es ist so eklig
einfach nur ich würde sagen dass die anwendung oder sowas es ist so eklig
Shelly ist jetzt der Default Package Manager bei CacheOS?
Wirklich?
Nö.
Hab ich nicht drauf.
CacheOS Package Installer?
Das da vielleicht?
Ist das Shelly?
Keine Ahnung.
warst du von dem arch user repo hack betroffen?
Ne, ich habe in der Zeit einfach glücklicherweise nicht geupdatet.
Und ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich Packages hatte, die betroffen waren.
Leute, Xamel ist so hässlich.
xml
soll ich euch mal sagen, ganz ehrlich
ich würde lieber
mein UI komplett
in C-Sharp definieren
als das hier mit diesem komischen
xml
ich fand das noch nie
noch nie nice und umso mehr
ich sehe, selbst nach
über 15 Jahren oder so
wann die das eingeführt haben mit WPF
Vor 20 Jahren haben die es mit WPF eingeführt.
Samuel ist legit goated.
Was? Alter!
Okay, Chat, da brauchen wir jetzt
eine Umfrage.
Da brauchen wir jetzt eine Umfrage.
Das bearbeitet man doch nicht von Hand.
Doch.
Es gibt auch grafische Editor,
aber doch, doch, die Leute schreiben das von Hand.
Was haltet ihr von Xaml?
Goated.
Geht so.
Sucked.
So, Start Vote.
Also, ja.
Was haltet ihr von diesem XML-Dialekt, um seine GUI zu definieren, ja?
Hier, so legt man da zum Beispiel einen Crit an.
Crit Column 1, Column Spacing.
Crit-Column-Dings.
Ich finde das so eklig, XAML, Alter.
Ich weiß, dass du das ernst meinst.
Ich weiß, dass du das ernst meinst,
aber ich kann es nicht verstehen.
Es ist definitiv bei mir
auch ein Skill-Issue,
aber
es sagt trotzdem.
Die Hälfte hat es noch nie gesehen.
Ist ja auch okay.
Da könnt ihr jetzt euren ersten Eindruck schildern.
Okay, wir haben auch einige XAML-Fans.
Also, wisst ihr, es gibt ja auch die Möglichkeit, dass das GUI...
Okay, okay.
Oh, I notify property changed.
WPF-Flashbacks, Alter.
Ist das...
Ich mein, C-Sharp ist eine wirklich schöne Programmiersprache.
Aber OMG, Alter, GUI-Kram.
Hör mal auf.
das eine hat mit dem anderen nichts also es gibt keine möglichkeit dort net guis in in
jammer zu definieren das gibt es nicht gibt noch sammeln ok also so ist recht gespalten ja viele
sagen geht so ein paar zwei sagen gott und wie sagt sagt aber wahrscheinlich ich würde es mal
tatsächlich hier auf 50 50 aufrunden weil viele leute haben das noch nicht gesehen und haben jetzt
halt gesehen, dass ich das flame und
finde es dann halt auch nicht gut. Also sagen wir mal so,
die Meinung ist ziemlich 50-50.
Genau, haben es noch nicht verwendet und so.
Also ich würde mal sagen, die Meinung ist ziemlich 50-50.
Aber wenn du es gut findest,
habe ich ja keine Probleme damit, ne?
Also, ist ja schön, wenn dir das gefällt.
Ich finde es eklig.
So, was trenne ich denn sonst noch?
CraftQL?
Den habe ich sogar auch schon benutzt.
Diesen Hot-Chocolate-CraftQL-Server.
Den haben wir sogar im Stream schon benutzt.
Richtig nice.
Ich mag eh CraftQL.
Vom Prinzip her.
Finde ich das nice.
Api Support for your favorite
Choron Trackers, ah für die Deluxe Distributionen
zum runterladen
Git Credentials Manager
nicht so spannend
ok, dann schauen wir mal, hier, was machen die
Krustentiere diese Woche
Herder
hatten wir schon, Cube Sandbox
AI, AI, Surreality B
Deno, Deno hat jetzt
was Neues, Chat
Deno hat jetzt, guckt euch das mal an, was sagt ihr dazu?
Das würde mich mal interessieren, was sagt ihr dazu?
Deno Desktop
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was ihr dazu sagt
Chatge
Also ich sag das jetzt nochmal, falls man es nicht mitgekriegt hat.
Deno hat jetzt die Möglichkeit Desktop-Anwendungen zu packagen.
So ein bisschen wie Tauri, ja?
Oder wie Elektron.
Wir gucken uns das mal kurz an, weil ich finde das an sich eigentlich recht spannend,
dass es das gibt.
Hallo, lautes Intro.
Was mich ja interessieren würde ist,
wenn die kein Chromium haben,
wie rendern die das dann?
Weil er hat ja gesagt, Single Binary.
Das heißt, du hast nicht,
du brauchst keine Abhängigkeiten
zum System.
Was wiederum bedeutet,
du musst eigentlich unter Linux
dein eigenes
Lib Webkit shippen.
Weil,
ansonsten müsste es ja über das System...
Ja, Tauri braucht
auch Lib Webkit unter Linux.
Okay, Basic-To-Do-App
Chat, wisst ihr was?
Ich glaube,
Deno hat diese Funktion gevibe-coded
Rate ich jetzt einfach mal so
Ach ja.
Das ist ja schon mal cool, dass das Weltkit Apps bundeln kann.
Cool.
Das kann sogar Hot Module Replacement oder wie das heißt.
Also du kannst quasi dann was editieren und speichern und die Anwendung reloadet deine Änderungen gleich.
Also wie Elektron.
Weil Elektron ist ja eine Mischung aus Node.js und Chrome und die kannst du quasi bridgen damit.
Die Seite gucken wir uns gleich an, Chad.
Jetzt kommt der Part, der mich interessiert.
Also bei Electron hast du halt ein komplettes Node.js und einen kompletten Chrome mit dabei.
Ja gut, ja gut, aber was ist, wenn du unter Linux WebKit nicht installiert hast?
Dann geht die Anwendung nicht, ne?
Okay.
Ja gut, also wenn das Chromium Embedded bundelt, ist das dann so ein großer Unterschied zu Elektron?
Was? App-Image, Depp oder RPM on Linux?
Ja, das ist ja komplett unsinnig.
App-Image sackt einfach hardcore.
Ich dachte, die hauen da ein schönes Native Binary raus.
was ohne Gefrickel einfach startet.
Ja, das ist ja schon wieder unsinnig für Linux Deployments dann.
Ja, das finde ich schon mal nicht so geil.
Okay, dann gucken wir jetzt nochmal die Webseite an.
AppImage ist doch ein Single Binary.
Ja, ja, ist es, ist es.
Aber AppImage hat trotzdem Dependencies zu Systemlibraries.
Und das fällt auch öfters mal ganz gerne.
Oder teilweise Probleme mit Integration
Hier in der Traybar und sowas
Also Comparison with other tools
Elektron
Elektro
Elektro-Bann
Gibt es das auch?
Das ist Elektron
Das ist Elektron für Bann, oder wie?
Tauri
Dioxus
Chat, ich muss mal kurz mein Headset rausziehen.
Warte mal kurz.
Stack.
So.
Jetzt sind wir wieder am Start.
Stachelt sind wir am Schlacht.
Ah ja.
App Size.
Geil.
Okay, guck mal.
Das ist 150 MB.
Also das macht eigentlich, wenn ich Chromium Embedded verwende, überhaupt keinen Unterschied zu Elektron.
Ja.
Also ich weiß nicht.
Chat, was sagt ihr dazu?
irgendwie
schockt es mich jetzt nicht so richtig.
Ich mag ja
solche Dinger, ne? Sowas, so
Bundletools,
die Single Binaries erzeugen.
Aber
ich glaube, das bringt mich
nicht zu
Deno.
Glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass mich das zu
Deno bringt.
Okay, schauen wir mal weiter
Was sonst noch trendet
Bei JavaScript
Git-Kompatibel
Okay
Das ist auch wieder so ein Ding
Ja, lass uns mal Git rewriten in Rust
But why?
But why? Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Oh, scheint ein bisschen älter zu sein, hä?
Oder auch nicht.
Ne, vor drei Tagen.
Warum müssen wir Git in Rust rewriten?
Warum ist das jetzt viel geiler als Git?
Okay, das ist mir zu viel Text, keine Ahnung.
Macht Rebase wohl viel einfacher?
Okay.
Sogar nicht, dass das großartig kompliziert ist in Git.
Habe ich nicht von Theon ein Video gesehen, vor einem halben Jahr oder so,
dass die darauf umsteigen, aber die sind gefühlt eh nur damit beschäftigt,
ihre Anwendung zu rewriten und ihre Sachen zu ändern.
Es muss alles in Rust rewritten werden.
AI?
AI
VPN-Stells
Rust Desk
Für die
Für den Microsoft Gold Support aus Indien
Don't redeem
Ich gucke in letzter Zeit weniger Scambaiting-Videos
Ich hab mal ne Zeit
Da hab ich jeden Tag Kid Boga und sowas geguckt
Aber es wird mit der Zeit schon langweilig
Weil es ist schon irgendwie immer das gleiche
Ich habe nur mitbekommen, dass die ganzen indischen Scammer, die verwenden Anydesk und Rustes mittlerweile wohl auch.
All in one Mail
und
Collaboration
Dieses Wort, Alter.
Collaboration.
Server.
Secures.
Okay, was kann das Ding?
Wie kannst du das schauen,
ohne fremd zu schämen?
Es ist schwierig.
Wahrscheinlich gucke ich das deswegen auch nicht mehr.
Und weil es langweilig wird.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Eigentlich ist es überhaupt nicht der richtige Content für mich.
Das kann IMAP, JMAP.
Was zum Teufel ist JMAP?
E-Mail-Protokoll.
JSON-Meta-Application-Protokoll.
Was auch immer.
Also der CardDuff-Server ist das einzige, was ich noch verwende von Nextcloud.
Da habe ich halt die Kontakte drin gespeichert.
Makro.
Okay, AI.
AI.
Fast and user-friendly alternative to find.
Selbst, das habe ich sogar schon ein paar Mal verwendet, aber selbstverständlich ist natürlich, natürlich Leute, find auch rewritten worden in Rust.
Bundler, Just, WorkMux, SpaceDrive, Cross-Plattform File Explorer, aha.
Solana.
Blockchain-Stells.
So, komm, wir quälen uns jetzt zum Schluss nochmal.
Zack. Aber das will ich mir gerade nochmal kurz angucken.
Gibt es da vielleicht...
Screenshots oder so?
Java. Okay, Java.
Java gucken wir.
Okay, dann gucke ich mir lieber Java an,
bevor ich mir C++ angucke.
Welcome to Space Drive.
What is Space Drive?
okay man kann sich halt einfach sachen anzeigen lassen von verschiedenen quellen
rock was braucht ist nice maven trendet ok
chat für die du hattest du letztens cosmic ausprobiert ja ich glaube wir
haben uns cosmic in der vm installiert mit cash ios der war aber glaube ich
ziemlich schlecht voreingestellt.
Das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Aber das war, glaube ich, nicht repräsentativ dafür.
Chat, ich hatte letztens
mal mit einem unserer ehemaligen
Entwickler auf der Arbeit telefoniert.
Und der hat mir erklärt,
dass Cradle eigentlich so der neue
Scheiß ist bei
Java-Anwendungen.
Aber er schwört auf Maven, einfach weil wohl dieses Dependency-POM-File viel klarer und besser lesbar ist und man besser durchblickt.
Was sagt ihr, Chat, für die Java-Kenner?
Cradle oder Maven?
Ich habe bisher nur Maven verwendet. Cradle habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Falls wir irgendwelche Java-Checker-Mans im Chat haben.
Aber so wie ich immer Java am Flamen bin, haben wir da wahrscheinlich keine.
Ich finde das PommeXML auch besser lesbar.
Java Chats, genau.
Maven hat halt deutlich mehr Plugins, darum bleiben wir bei Maven.
Okay, leuchtet ein.
Das hat er mir auch erzählt, hat auch gesagt, Maven ist halt relativ easy und klar und wenn
du was custom machen willst, musst du dein eigenes Plugin
programmieren.
Und in Cradle kannst du wohl
in der Config-Datei selber
wohl, ähm,
da ist auch wohl irgendwie so eine
Scripting-Möglichkeit drin.
Also ich hab bisher nur
Maven verwendet, bei meinen
Springboot und Quarkus
Experimenten.
Okay, Jenkins trendet.
Zu Recht, ich mag Jenkins.
Ich weiß, Leute, ihr mögt Jenkins nicht, aber ich mag Jenkins.
Ich würde jetzt auch, ich wäre jetzt, okay, ich muss dazu sagen, ich wäre jetzt auch nicht gerade scharf darauf.
einen neuen Jenkins aufzusetzen und zu betreiben und einzurichten.
Aber an sich mag ich Jenkins,
weil es halt irgendwie einfach, wie soll ich sagen, so...
So wenig Magic. Jenkins ist halt einfach so stumpf.
Du sagst hier, Job, führe mir dieses Bash-Skript aus im Zweifelsfall,
pull vorher dieses Git-Repo und dann ist gut.
Pipelines in Jenkins soll wohl absoluter Paints-Champ sein,
habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber ich hab ein Herz für Jenkins
Aber ich bin ja eh nicht normal
Ich mag auch Nagios
Auch wenn ich kein neues Nagios mehr installieren will
Jenkins hat sich mittlerweile umbenannt
Der Ensemble ist aber kein Ersatz für Jenkins
Jenkins ist eher so ein CI
zentraler
CI-CD-Server.
Und Ansible ist ja für
Server-Konfigurationen.
Ist Jenkins
wie GitHub Actions nur größer?
Also man könnte sagen,
die Tools sind in der gleichen Kategorie,
aber komplett anders.
Jenkins ist sehr Web-Interface
driven, zumindest
zu dem Zeitpunkt, als ich es das letzte Mal benutzt habe.
Wie sehr Web-Interface
driven, was vielen schon mal nicht
gefiel schon mal nicht gefällt und man muss das bringt also gut wie nichts mit
du musst dann alles selbst machen du kannst ja sagen checkt dieses geht
repo aus und dann dieses script github actions ist viel deklarativer und bringt
auch viel mehr mit
Elasticsearch.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich heute,
wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste zwischen
ich setze den Jenkins auf und bastle
eigenen Kram oder ich benutze
GitHub und GitHub Actions, würde ich mich
wahrscheinlich auch immer für GitHub und GitHub Actions
entscheiden.
Es sei denn, du hast halt irgendwas,
wo du viel frickeln musst,
wo sich den Jenkins besser anbietet.
Ja, oder du willst was, was
intern läuft und regelmäßig
Shops scheduled und vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt
nicht hauptsächlich
Sachen bildet
und deployt oder hauptsächlich bildet,
sondern auch irgendwelche anderen Automatisierungen
ausführt. Mit Jenkins kannst du
halt relativ easy alles machen. Du musst es
aber halt auch selbst machen. Und bei GitHub
Actions, das ist schon sehr stark
fokussiert auf
Software bauen und Container Images
bauen und sowas.
Wobei du
natürlich potenziell in github actions auch sehr viel anderes zeug machen kannst
kann sie also gar einen eigenen runner installieren der dann bei dir zugriff
auf irgendwelche internen ressourcen hat und sowas geht ja auch alles google core
libraries für java nachkurs von die china chinesen
AI Cloud Native Applications.
Jawoll.
Hab ich ja gerade gesagt,
dass du mit Actions auch alles machen kannst.
Aber der Fokus bei Actions ist ganz klar
auf Software bilden
und Container Images bilden
und sowas.
PDF-Stells
Minecraft, Java
Aha
Wir können
Java Minecraft Edition Server mit
Minecraft Bedrock Edition spielen
Selenium
Ah, das gibt es immer noch
Das ist so die
Ur-Browser-Automatisierung schlechthin.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja da schon
zig andere Dinger.
Da müsst ihr mir mal ein bisschen
auf die Sprünge helfen. Puppeteer gibt's.
Playwright gibt's.
Und was ist jetzt der neueste Shit nochmal gewesen?
Es gibt ja noch so ein drittes,
was jetzt voll neu und im Trend ist.
Browser-Automation-Geschichte.
Ähm.
Weiß nicht.
Da gibt es doch noch mehr.
Da gibt es doch jetzt eins, was voll...
Cypress?
War Playwright das Neueste?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht
Ich habe letztens was gesehen, was jetzt
wieder voll angesagt ist
Ja, Browser-Automatisierung
Du kannst damit Frontends testen, aber nicht unbedingt
Ja, also ich habe beispielsweise
auf der alten Arbeit mit Puppeteer
was gebaut, was
sich bei einem Anbieter
einloggt, der E-Mails als
Spam filtert oder
detektet und dort regelmäßig
die Quarantäne freigibt.
Und das ging nur über Browser-Klicken,
weil die keine API angeboten
haben. Die haben übrigens,
die haben übrigens die
beste Ausrede gehabt,
warum es das nicht gibt, ja.
Wir haben da hingeschrieben,
oder auch mal einen von denen gefragt, so nach dem Motto,
ey, guck mal, wir haben hier den Anwendungsfall,
wir wollen regelmäßig
alles, was hier in Quarantäne gelandet ist,
wollen wir regelmäßig freigeben.
Warum
habt ihr keine API, um sowas zu machen?
Und dann haben die gesagt, als Antwort
hat drauf, ah, ein sehr guter
das ist fast schon ein bisschen Chat-GPT
Antwort, ah, ein sehr guter Vorschlag,
wir haben dazu intern auch schon
einen Feature-Request offen.
Das war die Erklärung
dafür, warum es, also
die haben quasi vermieden
zu sagen, haben wir nicht, haben wir auch
keinen Bock drauf.
Und das war dann immer ihre Antwort,
wir haben da intern schon einen Feature-Request
dazu offen. Ja, geil!
Schön für euch, wenn ihr da einen Feature-Request offen habt.
Kann ja sein, ja.
Ist ja möglich.
Juckt mich aber nicht.
Das gibt es auch noch?
Das ist auch so uralt.
Uraltes Zeug.
Das war so die Zeit, wo MapReduce auch so ein Buzzword war.
Irgendwie habe ich das Problem
Ich glaube mein Kopfhörer, warte mal
Chat, ich muss das mal kurz ausprobieren, ob das mein Kopfhörer ist
Oder nicht
Ist das mein Kopfhörer? Sekunde
Chat, mal ausprobieren
Test, Test, Kopfhörer-Test
Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu
Äh
Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu
Ähm, ich glaube
Das ist mein, ich glaube das ist mein Kopfhörer
Der rumspackt
Oh, Chat, ich glaube ich brauche bald mal einen neuen
Ich habe jetzt nämlich den anderen Kopfhörer aufgehabt
Und da höre ich links und rechts genau gleich viel
Und auf dem
Auf dem Beyerdynamics
Auf dem höre ich manchmal rechts
Bisschen weniger
Komisch, ne?
Ich habe es die ganze Zeit auf mein Ohr geschoben
Aber es liegt nicht an meinem Ohr
Und es ist witzigerweise auch nur
Bei meiner eigenen hier Rückkopplung
Was ich
Wenn ich da reinspreche
Also sehr sehr merkwürdig eigentlich
Stop using this headphone, seriously.
Not safe.
Okay, das können wir uns gleich noch angucken.
Der macht immer gute Videos.
Keycloak.
Keycloak ist auch POG.
So, dann haben wir Github-Trends.
Haben wir durch.
Hast du dein Headset schon neu gestartet?
Ich habe letztens Firmware-Updates
von meinen Fahrradpedalen gemacht.
Kein Witz.
Meine Pedale haben ein Firmware-Update gebraucht.
Dann schauen wir uns das doch mal an, würde ich sagen.
Stop using these headphones, seriously.
Naja, mittlerweile könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es Kopfhörer gibt mit Internet-Access und sowas.
Ne, Fahrradpedale haben keinen Internet-Access, das geht über Bluetooth.
Ich weiß nicht, wann die Anwendung von Beats erhoben wurde, aber beziehungsweise hat Beats by Dre die Studio Buds, die ein Bluetooth-Headphone sind.
Es ist ein Wireless-Headphone, das man mit einem Gerät verbinden kann.
Das ist ziemlich einfach.
Das Problem ist, dass es wie jeder anderen Protokoll, die Bedeutung hat,
die Möglichkeit hat, jemanden zu bekommen, vielleicht Code-Execution oder vielleicht Verurteilung oder Spionage auf den Headphones,
was auf seiner eigenen Seite in einem einzigen Fall ein großer Deal ist, aber nicht so überraschend.
Das kann passieren.
Aber was verrückt ist, ist, dass es letzte Woche herausgekommen ist.
Wenn man sich tief in die echten Werte dieses Artikels befindet,
dann bemerkt man ein weiteres Artikel, das über ein Jahr hervorgehoben wurde.
Bluetooth-Frauen können Hacker durch den Mikrofon spüren lassen.
Also dieses Artikel ist nur die Publikation von Apple,
die ihre Version des Bug ausführen kann.
Aber das ist Forschung, die ein Jahr hervorgehoben wurde...
Das geht dann auch über Bluetooth oder so.
Oder über Ant. Ich glaube Ant ist das.
Was? Wer ist das?
Moment.
Der Frieder Steinmetz.
Nicht nur ein Paar oder zwei Headphones, sondern ein gesamtes Chipset, das mehrere Verkäufer aufbauen, um Headphones zu produzieren,
das ich noch nicht mehr darüber gesprochen habe.
Ich höre es gerade noch.
Wie Sie sehen, ist die Liste von Headphones groß, um einige große Spieler zu inkludieren,
wie einige Bose-Headphones, einige Jabra-Headphones, einige JBL-Headphones, Marshall, viele von ihnen, Sony, viele, viele, viele Sony.
Die Liste geht weiter.
Was ist die Verletzung?
Es gibt eine Firma namens Aroha.
Aroha, I'm just gonna say Aroha, that's probably wrong.
I'll also speak a little bit of Spanish with Aroha.
Aroha, so C, System on a Chip,
which basically are the chip that is doing the Bluetooth, right?
It is a controller that is meant to do the communication
to speak Bluetooth.
It is a Bluetooth system on a chip.
Now, when you are a manufacturer
or somebody that wants to develop with these systems on a chip,
what's gonna happen is the company is going to give you
not only the chip, but the SDK,
the Software Development Kit, that allows you to...
Gut, ist ja beim ESP32 das Gleiche.
Right your code on top.
Right.
It wouldn't make sense for them to hand you like the chip and a data sheet.
They have to give you something else to work with.
Right.
They have to give you the actual code that allows you to talk to the chip
to give you abstractions to actually use it.
And here's the problem that SDK, the one that all these headphone vendors
depended on, has these three vulnerabilities missing authentication
for Yacht Services.
I'm not going to say it again, but I thought that was funny.
Missing authentication for Bluetooth.
GATT ist
irgendwelches Bluetooth Gedöns.
... BR-EDR and critical capabilities of a custom protocol.
This is where it gets in, like, again, the world of embedded devices.
I've made videos on this. I have another video coming out.
Kurz gucken, sind da auch Shocks, Shocks-Headphones dabei gewesen?
I've made videos on this. I have another video coming out
on, like, just random Timu-embedded shit.
The world of embedded devices never ceases to amaze me
in how they are somehow...
Sekunde, wo hat denn Lister nochmal gezeigt?
... custom protocol.
Sind da Shocks dabei? Nee.
Okay, habe ich aber Glück gehabt.
Wer hat sich denn dieses GUI für das Ding ausgedacht?
Das sieht ja grausam aus, Alter.
Das ist schlecht.
Also sprich, jeder, der in die Nähe von dem Headphone kommt,
kann sich da per Bluetooth
connecten und es reconfiguren.
Okay, wenn er es sehr laut macht,
kann ich jetzt auch sehr laut machen, Leute.
Chatke, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Wenn jetzt mein Browser
da mitmacht.
Wenn ihr gerade dabei seid.
Ihr wisst ja, Storage ist gerade richtig teuer.
Da habe ich was für euch.
Und zwar könnt ihr bei mir auf dem Channel hier diesen Link anklicken.
Oder ihr könnt auch im Chat Ausrufezeichen, Ugreen Ausrufezeichen, Seagate machen.
Und es anklicken.
Da kommt ihr bei Alternate in einem Custom Shop raus.
Da gibt es aktuell 8, 4 und 6 Terabyte Platten.
Und es gibt relativ günstige Bundles mit Ugreen Assets.
Da könnt ihr euch zum Beispiel hier ein Low Power x86 NAS kaufen mit einem 4-Kern Intel CPU und 2,5 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte. Die CPU hat Crypto Extensions und Quick Sync, das heißt ihr könnt auch Videos transcoden, eben im Maßen, ja, Videos transcoden und auch mit verschlüsselten Festplatten kriegt ihr da die 2,5 Gig wahrscheinlich halbwegs saturated.
Wenn ihr euch das Bundle hier kauft oder Festplatten kaufen wollt oder sonst was, müsst ihr einfach nur auf meinen Link gehen.
Das Ganze könnt ihr euch hier angucken, draufklicken, in den Warenkorb, bam, bestellen und gut ist.
Und wie gesagt, das Ganze gilt nur über meinen Link.
Ansonsten kostet es mehr.
So, Sellout Ende.
Sekunde, das muss ich mir jetzt aufschreiben, da ich Sellout gemacht habe.
die preise sind wirklich nicht schlecht
fünfte siebte
zwei stunden
kann er live transcoding genauso gut wie die sein ology play serie ich habe
keine ahnung ich weiß auch nicht wie gut das transcoding bei mehreren streams
funktioniert also ein video sollte da denke ich problemlos funktionieren mit
quick sync support auf der cpu
Hm, ansonsten kann ich das nicht vergleichen, weil ich das noch nicht hatte. Keine Ahnung. Wie gesagt, man muss aber dazu sagen, das sind Einsteiger-Nassgeräte, die haben jetzt keine ultra krasse Power, also ob du da jetzt irgendwie 8K-Videos transcoden kannst, 5 Stück gleichzeitig, das bezweifle ich.
ob du überhaupt 8K Videos
on the fly transcoden kannst, bezweifle ich
aber 1080p
on the fly dürfte wahrscheinlich kein Problem sein
und 4K on the fly, ich weiß nicht
wie gut die QuickSync Geschichte da ist, vielleicht
auch, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht
can QuickSync
Transcode
4K Video
yes
Scheint ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Ja, das kann das anscheinend.
Aber wahrscheinlich kannst du da nicht so viele Videos auf einmal machen bei der CPU.
Aber das QuickSync drin ist und Crypto Extension ist wirklich ein huge win für das Ding.
Gucken wir mal Video weiter.
Moment, wo waren wir denn?
Da.
Das ist immer noch sehr laut.
Ist das immer noch Sellout?
Now, a simple protocol with some simple lack of authentication.
What could be so incredibly wrong with that?
Oh! Ja, gut. F.
link register something to point back to your show code and hook the stack or whatever to get
code execution also du kannst du kannst quasi ohne authentifizierung wireless diese headphones
hijacken und da custom code drauf ausführen geil dass das brauchen wir das so muss das sein
Kannst du gar eine Custom-Firmware ohne Authentifizierung drauf flashen oder was?
Es wird ja immer besser.
Also im besten Fall machen dir nur Wireless dein Headset kaputt.
Das ist gelblich, ja.
of devices we're talking about here and again this is just the ones that these people these
researchers went out and were like oh okay this chipset is in this device and it uses this sdk so
it is vulnerable there are probably other devices that are also vulnerable that no one is talking
about right but again you could write yeah i'm not saying to do this i'm saying from like a defense
standpoint like literally this is a bet this could be this could be bad you could write a wormable rce
die diese Version anzieht und in dieser Mauer weiß, dass sie andere Mauer, andere Headphones schießen.
Es gibt nur ein Netzwerk von Headphones. Oh, ich glaube, eine der Dinge, die du wissen solltest, ist, dass du quasi ein
ein Bluetooth Headset Botnet bauen kannst.
Wie, was machst du, wenn du diese Headphones aufkommst?
Nun, diese Headphones sind einfach nur eine Bluetooth Interface.
Und Bluetooth verbindliche Geräte sind tatsächlich sehr privilegiert in einem Handy.
Oh, how you can't just pair an arbitrary piece of headphone
to an arbitrary piece of phone.
Ah, if you were to do, for example, dump RAM command
and see if I can find it RAM, RAM, RAM, RAM.
Yeah, if you want to read all the RAM from the device,
you can dump the Bluetooth link table, which has a cryptographic keys
that headphone is using to authenticate with the phone.
And then you can pull those keys down.
Das heißt, du kannst dein eigenes Gerät
quasi pären mit dem Smartphone
und diese Headphones veröffentlichen.
Und dann kannst du plötzlich auf Anrufe einsteigen.
Du kannst jeden Art von Befehl anrufen,
den ein Hand-freies Gerät auf dem Handy machen könnte.
Du kannst ihre Kontakte lesen.
All das alles, nur weil der Headphone einen Bug hat.
Das bedeutet nicht nur ein Bluetooth-Klassiker,
wie der normale, gepaart und authentifiziert Bluetooth,
sondern auch Bluetooth-LE, Bluetooth-LO-Energie,
was mehr die simpler Version von Bluetooth ist.
Also, das ist der Art von Bug,
wenn Leute sagen, oh, ist Black Hat gefährlich?
Soll ich einen Burner-Phone bringen?
Ich meine ganz im Ernst,
Niemand, der nicht technikaffin ist, patcht sein Headset regelmäßig.
Sofern es fraglich ist, ob es da überhaupt schon Firmware-Updates für gibt.
Die haben aber ewig gebraucht, oder?
Anyway, thanks for watching, I appreciate it. Love you.
Oh!
Das ist zu heftig.
51 Minuten Video.
Da sitze ich ja 3 Stunden hier.
Moin, Sarix.
Was passiert mit euren Social Media Accounts nach dem Tod?
Einfach nicht sterben. Easy fix.
Alter, was sind das immer für komische Shorts, Alter?
Was zum Teufel ist überhaupt
Hobbyhorsing? Was soll das?
Achso
What the fuck?
Ich hab noch nicht
ein Short auf diesem Account geguckt, ne?
Das heißt im Endeffekt
das hier
ist anscheinend Sachen
was sich Leute
auf YouTube so angucken. Ja okay, das hier wahrscheinlich
ich ehrlich.
Der Widerspruch
moderner Beziehungen. Welche
Beziehung, Alter?
Da ist ja wirklich diesmal nichts
dabei.
Hobby-Horsing. Ich wusste bis jetzt
nicht mal, dass es das gibt.
Okay, das hat mich jetzt irgendwie neugierig
gemacht. Was ist...
Was ist Hobbyhorsing?
Was es nicht alles gibt, man!
Auf der anderen
Seite soll jeder machen, was ihn happy
macht, oder?
wenn sie gerne Hobby-Horsing betreibt.
Für viele junge Fans ist Nele ein großes Vorbild.
Andere machen ihren Sport zum Ziel von Hate.
Auf Social Media ist es halt sehr krass, weil die Leute...
Es wird... Leute, das hat nichts mit Hobby-Horsing zu tun.
Es wird jeder im Internet gehatet.
Das ist normal.
Super viel Trauen.
Das geht von unfassbar sexualisierenden Kommentaren natürlich.
Na gut, das wundert mich nicht.
Bis zu Morddrohungen und so.
Trotzdem wächst in der Szene aus dem Hass auch Stärke.
Du wirst überall geflamed.
Auch ich.
Gestern im Stream war einer da, der gesagt hat, er geht meine Katze überfahren.
... der Community viel mehr zusammenhalten.
Und das funktioniert auch ziemlich gut.
Und damit lässt sich jede...
Was sich alles gibt.
... Nele wird im Netz gehatet, nur wegen...
Wisst ihr, an was mich das ein bisschen erinnert?
Ich habe letztens
ein Path of Exile
Stream geguckt
und er hat
irgendwie zwischendurch
irgend so ein komisches
Anime Game gespielt
da musstest du
Pferdemädchen trainieren
Also das waren so Anime Girls
mit Pferdeohren und die
Die konntest du trainieren.
Mit, was weiß ich, dass sie besser springen können, mehr Ausdauer.
Da konntest du Equipment upgraden und sowas.
Ganz abgedrehtes Zeug, Alter.
Keine Ahnung, warum ich mir das angeguckt hab.
Zumindest, und dann konntest du, ja, da kannst du, genau, genau.
Und dann kannst du mit denen Wettrennen machen.
Ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt.
Das ist das ganz abgedrehte Zeug.
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Genau, genau, das meine ich.
Das da, das da.
Da habe ich irgendeinen Stream gesehen.
Eieiei.
So, irgendwie hat mich das ein bisschen daran erinnert jetzt.
Können wir ein Video über OpenCloud anschauen?
Wie lang ist das?
Weil ihr wisst, wenn ich lange Videos gucke, dann sind wir in Sitzung wirklich immer ewig an so einem Video,
weil ich ja alle 5 Sekunden dazu was zu sagen habe.
Also irgendwie ist heute auf YouTube aber wirklich nichts dabei.
Illegale Stadt in der Karibik.
Wen juckt's?
Peak Microslop.
Okay, das ist eher so eine Talkshow.
Warum wurde Deutschland so hässlich?
Und das geht ja hier sogar noch.
Okay, wartet mal.
Do it yourself Cloud Speicher.
Meine Cloud Alternative zu Next Cloud und Own Cloud.
Ich glaube, das ist langweilig, oder?
Okay, wir können mal reingucken.
Wir können mal reingucken.
Ich muss auch kurz die Musik ausmachen.
Okay, geht nur 11 Minuten, dann sind wir schnell durch.
In diesem Video möchte ich euch eine Dateiverwaltung vorstellen,
die kostenlos und open source ist.
Für alle Leute...
Open Cloud.
Ist Open Cloud diese...
...own cloud in go Geschichte jetzt?
ein eigenes smart home haben sie sind leise oder und zu hause hosten
ja das ist ein bisschen leise wartet mal ich muss ein bisschen lauter machen
youtube video möchte ich euch eine datei verwaltung vorstellen die kostenlos und
open source ist für alle leute die ein eigenes smart home haben dann zeigen wir
von zu hause ein bisschen vor für die könnte das ganze los geht interessant sein denn gerade
im vergleich zu bekannten projekt und laut hast du auch auf seiner stream ideenliste ja da steht
leider sehr viel drauf einige vorteile das war später mal wichtig dass geschichte anschauen
und zwar wo kommt eigentlich her das ganze basiert ähnlich wie die nextcloud auf dem
vorherigen projekt und das wurde damals zu einem kommerziellen projekt umgewandelt und
daraus haben sich eben zwei abspaltungen die bereits genannte nextcloud und eben das projekt
Die Nextcloud ist dabei auf den PH4-Standard und ist relativ bekannt geworden.
Hat mittlerweile neben der reinen Dateiverwaltung auch viele weitere...
Aber Nextcloud sagt genauso wie damals Oncloud.
...einen Chat, eine Kontaktfunktionalität, einen Kalender und vieles mehr.
Das heißt im Prinzip mittlerweile auch Nextcloud habt, weil ihr eben diese ganzen Sachen mit dabei bekommt.
Das Ganze hat auf der einen Seite natürlich Vorteile, eben diese ganzen Dienste, die ihr mit dabei bekommt,
auf der anderen Seite aber auch große Nachteile, da das Ganze zum einen aufzusetzen zwar relativ simpel ist,
aber dann eben vernünftig aufzusetzen, sodass das Projekt auch stabil läuft, gar nicht so einfach ist.
Das stimmt.
Und dann dafür gesorgt hat, dass...
Und außerdem, weil Nextcloud an vielen Stellen immer so unfertig ist.
...relativ unzufrieden damit bin.
Außerdem sind die ganzen Features natürlich Fluch und Segen zugleich, denn das Ganze ist natürlich extrem überladen mit jeder Menge Funktionen.
Open Cloud hingegen ist auch ein Open Source Tool, im Vergleich zu der Nextcloud noch super, super jung, möchte aber eben deutlich simpler sein, bietet also eher Basic Features wie zum Beispiel eine Benutzerverwaltung, eine Rechteverwaltung, Dateiverwaltung und so weiter an.
Das Ganze lässt sich natürlich auch über Plugins noch etwas erweitern, ist aber im Grunde genommen weitaus kleiner als eben die Nextcloud.
Was aber vor allen Dingen ein Riesenvorteil ist, ist die Programmiersprache, die deutlich moderner ist als die von Nextcloud und dadurch eben einige Performance-Vorteile hat, sowohl auf der Server-Seite als auch auf der Client-Seite.
Das Ganze seht ihr auch hier mal.
angenehmer zu entwickeln ist als in php von mir eingeblendet also ich zeig mal im hintergrund wie
ich dateien lade dateien entfernen und so weiter und so fort das funktioniert wirklich unfassbar
stabil und sauber und ist etwas was mir bei nextcloud wirklich extrem gefehlt hat ich muss
dazu sagen dass ich sowohl installation auf eigenen haushalt habe als auch tatsächlich
eine gehostete nextcloud bei hessener selber also theoretisch bei den leuten die das ganze
funktioniert und trotzdem immer wieder wie gesagt an ein oder andere stelle kleinere probleme
weswegen ich einfach grundsätzlich mit der nextcloud nicht mehr so 100 prozentig zufrieden
Wenn ich einen Nachteil an Open Cloud nennen müsste, neben natürlich dem eingeschränkten Funktionsumfang, einfach dem geschuldet, dass das ganze Projekt etwas simpler ist, dann wäre es auf jeden Fall die Installationsart und Weise, denn die Nextcloud ist natürlich sehr, sehr weit verbreitet. Lässt sich zum einen bei Hostern direkt buchen, zum Beispiel bei Hetzner oder eben auf jedem Betriebssystem quasi direkt mit installieren. Zum Beispiel bei Home Assistant lässt sich das Ganze direkt als Add-on installieren. Natürlich auch bei Proxmox Installationsanleihen.
treiben konnte, Müll zu können, mal von Proxmox Helper Scripts zu verwenden
und hier einfach eine komplett frische Ubuntu oder alternativ auch Debian VM zu verwenden.
Proxmox Helper Scripts.
Das habe ich jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal gesehen.
Ich habe davon Abstand gehalten bisher,
weil du immer nicht genau weißt, was diese Dinger eigentlich ausführen.
Und ganz ehrlich, eine Debian 13 VM habe ich auf meinem Proxmox auch in 30 Sekunden laufen.
gerade mit meinem
High IQ PXE Boot, den ich jetzt am Start
habe hier.
Oh, lasst uns gerade mal
testen, ob mein PXE Boot noch
funktioniert.
Weil ich hatte letztens
einen Stromausfall. Ich weiß nicht, ob der
Raspberry Pi noch funktioniert.
Lasst uns mal kurz
PXE Boot checken.
Haben wir hier
UEFI. Komm, wir machen mal BIOS.
Weil dann bootet das alte nicht und...
Netboot.
Äh...
VMware?
Hallo?
VMware sagt, nee, machen wir nicht.
Ist das jetzt komplett abgekackt oder was?
Alter, vor allem ja, was ist los?
Also das ist schon echt
Das ist schon echt schlecht geworden
Das neue Forever Workstage
Okay, Boot
Vom Netzwerk
Oh Leute, ich glaube der Raspberry Pi hat den Stromausfall
Nicht überlebt, kann das sein?
Okay, mein krasses
PXE Boot ist doch nicht so krass gerade
Weil es kaputt ist
Ich glaube irgendwie, das hat den Stromausfall nicht überlebt.
Okay.
Das sieht schlecht aus, ja.
Wir schauen mal kurz,
ob der an sich noch da ist.
Hi, Ad.
Ruth, Ad.
2-5-5.
Ist das der überhaupt?
Max add.
Da ist auch der PXE-Champ.
Uptime
Der Stromausfall hat dem nix gemacht
Stromausfall ist alles okay
Kein Problem
Warum geht mein PXE-Boot nicht mehr
System CTL
Status
Wie heißt dieses Ding aber ich muss kurz ein bisschen
Gedudel anmachen
Wie heißt dieses Ding, was ich da nochmal...
DNS-Mask?
Läuft?
ETC, DNS-Mask,
DNS-Mask-Conf.
Das ist bestimmt irgendein...
Das ist bestimmt...
Ich könnte wetten, dass es irgendein
Vor allem ein Problem.
Das liegt gar nicht an meinem...
Network is bridged.
Bridged.
Moment, was habe ich hier?
Was habe ich hier drin?
Auch bridged.
Bridged.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, warum das nicht PXE-Boot.
Das sollte jetzt eigentlich schön PXE booten.
Aber ich glaube, der Stromausfall hat doch irgendwas kaputt gemacht.
Ja, also das neue VML Workstation.
Also ich verstehe jetzt nicht, warum der nicht will.
Gibt es ein ordentliches Log von DNS Mask?
da machen wir was anderes system ctl system ctl stopp dns mask service
wir gucken jetzt einfach mal live zu hallo der raspberry pi hat irgendein
problem system ctl stopp dns mask dns mask wir führen das mal von hand aus
Achso, äh, kill all DNS-Mask, DNS-Mask, ah, DNS-Mask, wie konnte man diesen Kram im Vordergrund, minus D, DNS-Mask, minus D.
Okay, also, der lauscht hier auf jeden Fall schon mal.
Proxy on subnet, SAV TFTP root, also das ist alles okay.
Ja, das ist wie Set-Servers.
Ein bisschen. Nur, dass es jetzt mein eigener Raspberry Pi ist.
Okay. Starten wir nochmal.
Und sagen jetzt
Routen vom Netzwerk.
Da kommt nichts an.
Der ist netzwerktechnisch dead.
Doch jetzt.
Der antwortet.
Das ist irgendein
Das ist ir... Guck mal, der antwortet.
Das ist irgendein VM-er-Problem.
Dass der nicht
darauf antwortet jetzt.
Also, dass VM-er das davon nicht bootet.
Muss ich mal grad was ausprobieren.
Ich stell das mal...
Ich stell das hier mal wieder auf. Das ist irgendein VM-er-Problem.
Booten wir hier mal. Booten wir mal hier Efi.
Efi stellt's booten.
Das geht sofort
Über EFI bootet VMware
Über das andere nicht
Naja, zumindest
Weil ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte
Guck mal, wie schnell ich
Debian installiert habe
Also, ich boot ein paar PXE
Sag Install
Dann zieht er sich das aktuelle Debian Image
und dann startet er das ich führe setup aus ich sage ich will debian stable haben auf dieser disk
mit diesem Hausnamen
und
jetzt installiert
Herr Debian.
Und zack!
Ist Debian installiert. Ist das nicht nice?
Ein tagesaktuelles
Debian Stable.
Och, oder?
über PXE-Boot.
Und was noch viel nicer ist,
wenn es dann gestartet ist,
guckt mal,
steht sogar die IP da.
Da kann ich jetzt sagen, okay,
2119.
Ich hoffe, ich habe den Key da drauf.
SSH
2.119
als Debian.
Achso, ja ja.
Oh, ich hab mir doch so ein Skript gebastelt,
um das zu löschen.
Wie hieß das?
Ich hab doch so ein SSH.
Fixed SSH.
Yes.
Und schon sind wir auf der neuen Debian-Kiste drauf.
Also schneller...
Ups, jetzt hab ich voll reingeschrien.
Also schneller,
als dieses komische Custom
Script ist das jetzt auch nicht gewesen.
Langsamer.
Langsamer als dieses komische Custom Script
ist das jetzt auch nicht gewesen.
Warum vor allem er Probleme hat mit
BIOS Boot, verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht, weil mein PXE-Server
hat ja ganz normal geantwortet.
Keine Ahnung. Guckt und zack
haben wir hier jetzt eine neue
VM, wo wir per SSH draufkommen.
Und wisst ihr, was noch viel nicer
ist? Der installiert
jetzt sogar im Hintergrund noch ein paar Sachen.
Ja, man sieht es hier vielleicht.
Guck, falls er noch
installiert.
Ihr seht, der hat sogar
die VMware-Tools installiert.
Guck, der erkennt, dass er
auf VMware läuft.
Der hat sogar die VMware-Tools
jetzt automatisch installiert, weil er erkennt,
dass es eine VM ist,
die auf VMware läuft.
Wenn es eine KVM-VM
wäre, hätte er die
Cuemo-Tools installiert.
Das ist schon nice, oder?
Das macht er nämlich hier über diese...
Da habe ich so einen...
Das läuft über CloudInit.
Da habe ich hier so einen...
Ordner, Configs.
Und hier steht dann drin, was der quasi macht.
Der kopiert die SSH-Keys dahin.
Das ist ein CloudInit-File.
der kopiert die SSH-Kiste dahin auf eine neue Kiste, startet die Default-User, gibt die IP-Adresse beim Starten aus,
updatet das System, installiert hier ein paar Standard-Tools, guckt, ob es VMware ist, wenn es VMware ist, installiert er OpenVM-Tools,
quasi hier, mein Ansible-Lite und wenn es KVM ist, installiert er QEMU-Guest-Agent und ersetzt, ganz wichtig,
weil sonst kriege ich immer Anfälle.
Er setzt meinen Default-Editor auf WIM
und er schaltet
den Maus-Mode in WIM aus.
Das passiert automatisch, sobald ich eine Debian-Kiste
installiere. An sich ist das Setup
ein bisschen komplizierter, weil ihr habt ja gesehen,
das ist ein Customizer-Debian-Installer
oder so ein Fake-Debian-Installer.
Ich dd da halt einfach das ISO drauf
und passe was an. Also es ist schon
recht advanced, mein PXE-Boot, den ich hier
habe. Wobei das Coole ist halt,
was ich vielleicht auch nochmal zeigen kann
ich hab halt weekly
aktuelle
Skripts die laufen
ich hab halt hier
www.html
da haben wir hier irgendwie install
oder wo ich das hab
da gibt es ein update.sh
und das downloadet halt einmal die Woche
einmal die Woche
update das
lädt das sich die neuesten
Debian Isos runter
Stable Testing Unstable
Die neuesten Netboot XYZ
Images, das neueste
Clonezilla Image, das neueste Rescue
CD Image, Rescue CD mit
ZFS Image
Linux Mint Installer
Und dann hat es noch ein paar andere Dinger
Und ein CacheOS tatsächlich auch
Das updatet das einmal in der Woche, das heißt
Ich habe immer top aktuelle
Images, wir können auch gerade mal überprüfen
Guck vom 5.
vom 5 von heute nacht sind die heute morgen 6 49 hatte den neuesten dem wir ein images runtergeladen
so habe ich immer weekly weekly aktuelle images für alles mögliche die ich bei mir lokal einfach
pxe boot starten kann und wenn das nicht ausreicht kann ich vielleicht auch noch mal zeigen wenn das
nicht ausreicht wir wir wir rebooten jetzt wie wir rebooten jetzt noch mal und starten noch mal pxe
nochmal pxe starten
sollte das nicht ausreichen
was ich hier habe
auf meinen lokalen Images
habe ich immer noch Zugriff
auf das neueste Netboot XYZ
das ist so ein
das ist quasi so ein
Net, so ein Service
für Linux Images, die da übers Internet zieht
guck, wenn ich sage, also
das reicht mir alles nicht, was ich hier habe
kann ich auch immer noch Netboot XYZ
booten.
Das ist alles
bevor ein Betriebssystem startet oder so.
Netboot XYZ
und hier drin habe ich
jetzt so ziemlich alles, was es gibt
zum booten.
Also wenn ich
irgendwas bei mir nicht drin habe,
in Netboot XYZ
fit sogar drin sein. Ich könnte da drüber sogar
Windows installieren. Wenn ich hier
lokal das hätte, ja.
Ich könnte da drüber sogar Windows installieren.
Oder
BSD.
Ganz abgedrehtes Zeug.
Ist das nicht nice?
So.
Beende das mal wieder, weil ich will da nicht wirklich BSD installieren.
Okay, dann schauen wir mal weiter
Ja, Proxmox, Proxmox
Siehste, und ganz ehrlich, das ist mir lieber
So in 30 Sekunden
Aktuelles Debian zu installieren
Wie Proxmox
Helper-Skripts, weil in Proxmox Helper-Skripts hast du überhaupt
Keine Ahnung, was das ausführt
Und in Zeiten von Supply-Chain-Angriffen
Auf allen Ebenen und allen Ecken
Und Enden würde ich das am liebsten
Vermeiden, ne
Oh, ich krieg jetzt schon was zu essen
...
Ich bin kein Veganer. Ich bin ganz, wie nennt man das, reiner Eigennutz, dass ich veganes Hackfleisch esse. Mir geht es da nicht primär um das Tierwohl, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Mir geht es hauptsächlich um meine eigene Gesundheit, weil zu viel Fleisch essen ungesund ist.
Tierwohl ist Nebeneffekt, das nehme ich gerne
mit in Kauf, ja.
Dass das auch für die Tiere gut ist, wenn man
weniger Fleisch futtert.
Aber hauptsächlich mache ich es für meine eigene
Gesundheit.
Du kannst in das Skript reinschauen, ja.
So wie er das jetzt gerade auch macht, ne.
Du kannst auch
Linux Source Code lesen und den eigenen Kernel
kompilieren. Man kann viel,
aber dadurch, dass es so einfach ist, macht es kaum jemand.
Guck mal, man sollte auch nicht
Kernel nach Bash pipen. Und was machen
die meisten Leute Köln nach Beszp halten.
Hier das
Install-Skript zu kopieren,
bei Proxmox einmal
auf den Server zu gehen. Guck mal, guck mal, wie
kompliziert das ist. Da bin ich
mit meinem PXE-Boot viel schneller, oder?
Die Shell und dann
das Ganze hier einzufügen. Damit
erstellt ihr euch eine komplett neue virtuelle
Maschine, auf der dann eben Debian oder
Ubuntu installiert wird.
Das Ganze wird auch, wenn ihr hier
diesen Link kopiert, noch genauer
erklärt. Also hier findet ihr noch...
Chat, Chat, was findet ihr besser?
Irgendwelchen obskuren
Community-Skripts,
um noch vor allem installieren oder PXE-Boot
dreimal klicken und demian draufhauen.
Ja, da werden auch irgendwelche
Sachen unten drunter
ausgeführt, die ihr nicht nachgucken könnt,
aber das ist für mich kein Problem,
weil ich hab die, programmiert die Sachen
unten drunter. Ich weiß, was da
drin ist. Programmiert ist ein bisschen
übertrieben, bisschen Cloud-Init-Files
erstellt.
Du kannst aber einen gleichwertigen PXE-Server auch auf deinem Proxmox-System laufen lassen.
Ja, ob das auf dem Raspberry Pi oder auf dem Proxmox läuft, ist egal.
Aber einfach ist es nicht. Ich habe da ganz schön lange dran gepastelt.
Ich meine, guck mal, ich weiß, ich feiere es jetzt gerade super krass selbst,
aber das muss ich einfach nochmal zeigen, dass man sieht, dass da wirklich,
da steckt wirklich was dahinter.
So, wir booten das jetzt.
der holt sich jetzt per DHCP eine IP
und kriegt gesagt, ey guck mal hier
PXE Server gibt es da und da
dann bootet er sich das
dann bootet er sich das IPXE Image
vom PXE Server
beziehungsweise per HTTP
zieht er das, so und jetzt
habe ich mir hier ein schönes
Bootmenü gemacht
mit allen möglichen Sachen drin
die einmal in der Woche aktualisiert werden
habe ich euch ja gezeigt, da booten wir
jetzt nochmal den, also das hier sind
alles ganz normale Images.
Also ich kann CacheOS, das ist übrigens
eine KI-Katze.
Das ist ganz
zum Beispiel Mint.
Linux Mint. Mal gucken, ob das noch
funktioniert. Linux Mint kann ich
starten. Das wird auch einmal die Woche runter
geladen und präpariert, dass ich das über
PXE starten kann. So kann ich
ein Linux Mint Live-System starten im Endeffekt.
Aber
bei dem Debian-Installer, und das
startet jetzt ganz normales, guck mal,
das dauert jetzt halt ein bisschen. Es geht
aber immerhin noch schneller, als das
übers Internet zu ziehen, weil das über ein lokales
Netzwerk geht.
Das geht noch
halbwegs schnell.
Also übers Internet ist es nochmal deutlich langsamer.
Ja, deswegen mache ich kein Proxmox Cloud Init.
Proxmox Cloud Init
hatte mir zu viele Fallstricke und war
tatsächlich auch gar nicht so easy, wie ich gedacht habe.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt meinen eigenen PXE-Server laufen
Ich zeige das mit dem Debian-Installer gleich nochmal
Weil ich mich da voll für abfeiere
Im Endeffekt
Der PXE-Server hält selbst das ISO aktuell
Ja, guck, das funktioniert folgendermaßen
Ich habe hier so ein Update
Ups, äh, Moment
Zack, zack
Ich habe hier einen Update-Skript
Und das zieht sich halt einmal die Woche
Die neuesten Debian-Images
Das ist alles selbst gebaut, ja
Ich spiegel die Images lokal
Also ich spiegle mir Debian, Stable Testing und Unstable, aktuelles Image Netboot XYZ, aktuelles Image CloneZilla, aktuelles Image System Rescue CD, System Rescue CD Miners, aktuellen Mint Installer und aktuelles CacheUS.
ZFS Bootmenü aktuell nicht mehr.
Das funktioniert dann zum Beispiel folgendermaßen.
Update Debian.
Schon mal Nexus von SonarType.
Ne, wir haben Artifactory auf der Arbeit.
Guck, der macht hier eine Schleife über SIT-Stable-Testing.
So heißen halt die Debian-Distros immer.
Also beziehungsweise Distro ist eigentlich falsch.
Version oder irgendwie so müsste man das nennen.
Und dann guckt der hier per Curl.
Also das ist, ich habe es so weit automatisiert, dass man wenig kaputt gehen kann.
Also, der, wieso haben wir uns dafür entschieden, weiß ich nicht.
Das war schon da, bevor ich da war.
Keine Ahnung, warum wir uns dafür entschieden haben.
Guck, der geht in das Dists-Verzeichnis für die jeweilige Distro, also in dem Fall hier Dists Stable Release, holt sich daraus den aktuellen Codename raus, dann holt er sich mit dem aktuellen Codename Debian Daily Latest von den Latest Builds, holt er sich das aktuelle Image raus,
den Pfad zum
ISO-File
oder nee, die Version,
die aktuelle Version holt er raus.
Weil es könnte ja auch sowas sein,
Debian
Trixi 13.5
oder sowas, ja.
Holt er sich da raus für das Generic Cloud
Image, dann macht er ein bisschen
Cutmagic.
Und hier, das hier finde ich auch mega.
Dann lädt er sich halt das aktuelle
ISO runter und zwar
dafür braucht man Debian
Cloud Image, den Name,
also Trixi in dem Fall
und die Versionsnummer.
Das ist dann quasi hier, Trixi
Debian 13.5, ich weiß
nicht, ob Trixi 13 ist, ich rate es jetzt
einfach, ja. Generic, AMD,
Daily, Target Z, lädt er sich runter
und jetzt kommt Trick 17, passt mal auf,
jetzt kommt Trick 17.
Der enttart das Ganze
dann, das ist nämlich in Target Z das Image
und dann
LZ4-t
er dieses Image wieder,
in die Datei quasi
image-image-parse.lz4
Hat jemand von euch
eine Idee, warum ich nicht gleich
das fertige tar.xz verwende
und lieber lz4 benutze?
Also ich entpacke quasi das offizielle
tar.xz von demian
und lz4 kompresse mir das dann.
Immer eine klarreiche
Idee, warum lz4?
Ich leide gerne.
Nö.
Das hat damit aber nichts zu tun.
Kompression und schneller Laden. Korrekt.
LZ4 ist vielleicht ein bisschen weniger komprimiert.
Eventuell. Kann ich nicht sagen.
Das Gute ist aber, LZ4 entpackt schnell.
Und so habe ich die optimale Kombination aus Übertragungsrate und Entpackrate.
Das ist dann quasi sauschnell, wie das Image entpackt wird.
Für den Installer.
weil der kann sich das über HTTP runterladen
und on the fly auch sehr schnell
extracten, LZ4 ist quasi
extract optimized, du kannst das Ding
sehr schnell entpacken
das macht er dann für alle Debian
Distributionen, für Netboot
für Clonezilla
holt er sich hier die aktuelle Version
und lädt sich das runter, System Rescue CD
holt er sich hier
von dem Downloader
sich das, hier Linux Mint
und dann noch irgendwie die aktuellen
Debian Installer,
Old Stable Installer,
wenn wir die hier nicht wirklich brauchen.
Und jetzt will ich euch mal noch Magic zeigen.
Jetzt will ich euch mal noch Magic
zeigen und zwar, also ihr seht,
guckt, jetzt habe ich hier ein ganz normales
Linux Mint Installer gebootet.
So, wie
man das
sich auch als
ISO quasi laden kann.
Aber was ich noch
viel nicer finde ist
der Debian Installer.
Den finde ich so pock.
Den muss ich jetzt einfach nochmal zeigen.
Und zwar, wir booten nochmal PXE.
Weil ich habe euch ja gezeigt, ich lade mir
Debian ISOs runter
und LZ4e die.
Und mein Ziel ist ja, PXE-Boot
zu machen und möglichst schnell
den Debian zu installieren.
Also es gibt natürlich einmal die Möglichkeit, den ganz normalen Debian Installer hier drüber zu starten.
So, dann startest du den Debian Installer und dann musst du den Debian Installer halt ganz normal, wie ihr das kennt, hier durchklicken.
Englisch, United States, American English Keyboard, Blablabla.
Da bist du bestimmt gut und gern 5 Minuten beschäftigt, bis Debian dann wirklich installiert ist.
So, das müsstest du dann hier alles durchklicken, warten bis der seine IP-Adresse konfiguriert hat.
Dann macht er nochmal DHCP.
Bla, Host, Domain Name.
Also sprich, Mirror Archive.
Also sprich, ihr müsst quasi den Debian Installer durchklicken.
Ich habe mir das automatisiert.
Jetzt passt mal auf, jetzt wird es richtig advanced.
Er neu startet.
Ich habe mir einen eigenen Wrapper gebaut.
Quasi, also, das stimmt nicht so ganz.
Ich hab mir einen eigenen Debian-Installer gebaut
Der aber kein wirklich Debian-Installer ist
Der letztendlich nur das Cloud-Image drauf dedeht
So, pass mal auf
Ich boot jetzt hier für PXE
Und das find ich richtig geil
Das feier ich richtig ab
So, jetzt startet gleich das Boot-Menü wieder
Und jetzt geh ich hier, guck mal unten
Ventoy, nicht wirklich Ventoy
Ventoy kann ja auch den Debian-Installer
nicht automatisieren. Das heißt,
ich habe quasi einen eigenen Mini-Debian-Installer
gebaut. Guck mal hier, Install.
Install bootet
jetzt. Das muss ich jetzt erklären. Wenn ich das
hier boote, das bootet
eine Custom-Init-RAM
FS. Das
bootet quasi einen Custom-Linux,
was wir selbst gebaut haben,
in den RAM.
So, Install. Ihr seht es ja auch hier.
Init-RD-VM-Linux-Boot.
Der bootet quasi ein eigenes Linux, was wir gebaut haben, nur für den Installer.
Der Installer hat übrigens auch ein SSH laufen.
Und jetzt habe ich hier ein Setup-Skript.
Hier.
Wim.
Ja, okay.
Das ist nicht wirklich gut dafür.
Guck mal, ich habe hier ein eigenes Installer-Skript in dieses Linux reingelegt.
Der lädt sich jetzt von meinem PXE-Server einen Install.sh runter und führt das aus.
Warum benutzt du nicht Pre-Seeding?
Das hatte einen Grund.
Das hatte einen Grund, warum ich nicht Pre-Seeding...
Ja gut, weil er dann immer noch den Installer durchmachen muss.
Und weil das gar nicht so einfach war, einen Pre-Seed zu erstellen.
Da muss er immer noch den ganzen Installer durchmachen.
Mach mal einen Pre-Seed mit einem Custom-Host-Namen und sowas.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
ich will ja einen Pre-Seed haben
der dann auch, also ich will ja einen
Debian Installer installieren
was dann auch noch ein paar custom Sachen anpasst
mit einem Pre-Seed kannst du ja nur den Installer automatisieren
so viel mehr
das ist viel nicer so
also das führt jetzt den Install-Skript aus
dieses Install-Skript
hat jetzt quasi ein Menü
was ich auswählen kann, was ich installieren will
so Debian Stable
dann sucht das automatisch
die Festplatten, die drin sind, sage ich hier
ich will auf dieser Festplatte installieren
Da kann ich jetzt noch einen Host-Namen angeben, der schlägt mir defaultmäßig hier oben den da vor und jetzt dedet er, jetzt zieht er sich dieses LZ4-Image und dedet das auf die lokale Platte drauf und macht danach noch ein paar Anpassungen für CloudInit.
dann rebootet er
und jetzt führt er initial die gesamten
Cloud-Init-Geschichten aus
ich kann euch das gleich nochmal zeigen
und bei Cloud-Init sind dann so
Sachen drauf wie meine SSH-Keys
kommen rein, der Hostname
wird gesetzt
der Name für das
Netzwerkinterface wird richtig gesetzt
und was ich mega cool finde
ist, ich hab nen Prompt
wenn die VM zum ersten Mal startet
wo die IP-Adresse drin steht
Weil wer kennt es nicht, er installiert eine VM und fragt sich, welche IP hatten die VM jetzt bekommen.
Und dann geht ihr bei eurem Router in die DHCP-Übersicht und guckt, welche IP die zugewiesen bekommen hat.
Bei mir hat es das Debian so customised, dass ich direkt hier vorne auf dem Prompt schon stehen habe, was das für eine IP bekommen hat.
Das ist super easy. Und guckt mal, habt ihr gesehen, wie schnell die Debian-Installation jetzt ging.
Es war richtig Highspeed-Fast und ich kann euch jetzt mal zeigen, wie das unter der Haube funktioniert, weil das ist echt schon ein bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge.
ich bin mir gar nicht, hier install.sh
das ist das Installer-Skript
was wir gerade ausgeführt haben, was der hier macht
also
der macht mit
FZF ein Menü
wo ich auswählen kann
zwischen Stable, Testing, Sit, habt ihr gerade gesehen
dann listet er alle Festplatten
macht mit FZF ein Menü
wo ich die Festplatte auswählen kann
dann erzeugt er
random einen Hostname
den ich auch überschreiben könnte
wenn ich will, dann lädt er sich das
LZ4-Image runter von meinem Server,
was ich euch vorher gezeigt habe,
entpackt das und
dedät das auf die Disk, die ich hier oben
ausgewählt habe. Das ist quasi ein Custom Debian
Installer, den ich hier gebastelt habe.
Minimal Custom Debian Installer.
So, und jetzt kommt
Trick 17.
Der mountet sich
in das
Live-Linux-System,
das jetzt frisch
dedäte Image
nach MNT und
kopiert da Custom Cloud
Init Configs rein.
Und die
Custom Cloud Init Configs
sind dann halt unter anderem
solche Sachen hier.
Ja,
SSH Keys, Hostnamen
und
Post Run Commands.
Es ist super
durch die Brust ins Auge, aber
das ist, also auch
im Vergleich zu dem, wie wir es auf der alten Arbeit haben,
für mich ist das
der beste
lokale, so Linux
Provisioning Ding,
ja, Provisioning ist jetzt vielleicht zu viel gesagt, ja,
den ich bisher je
gebaut habe oder gesehen habe. Das funzt
einfach richtig, richtig gut.
Und
als Premium ist da, guck hier,
weil so ein Custom, so
ein Run-CMD kannst du mit dem
Pre-Seed ja auch nicht richtig machen,
sodass er das nach dem Boot dann
dann reinhaut.
Als Premium guckt er halt noch,
was für Virtualisierungstechnologie ist das?
Dann installiert er
VMware Tools, wenn es VMware ist, oder KVM,
wenn es QEMU ist. Und macht noch ein paar andere
Dinger. Es ist noch deutlich
komplizierter, wenn ich euch die ganzen anderen Sachen
zeigen würde.
Aber da kommt halt hier
einiges zusammen.
Guckt, das hier ist die Netzwerk,
die Netzwerk-Config.
Ich habe zum Beispiel hier auch eingeschaltet,
dass der
ETH0 verwendet für das erste Netzwerkinterface
und nicht diese komischen ENP33 und sowas.
Das ist schon sehr advanced.
Ja, und was ich jetzt vielleicht ganz außen vorgelassen habe,
was ich aber vielleicht auch nochmal zeigen sollte,
guckt mal,
das hier,
die sind vom 9. Februar.
Nee, ETH0 ist mittlerweile nicht mehr Default.
Die Dinger bei Raspberry Pi ist das.
Mittlerweile ist die Benamung so.
Das sind irgendwie nach PCI, PCI-ID oder sowas werden die Dinger jetzt standardmäßig benannt.
ETH0 gibt es nicht mehr.
Die Dinger heißen jetzt ENP2S0 und sowas.
Why?
Der Sinn dahinter ist sogar nachvollziehbar, dass die gleiche Netzwerkkarte immer den gleichen Namen hat.
Weil ETH0 musste nicht zwangsläufig, wenn du mehrere Netzwerkkarten hattest, immer ETH0 sein.
Immer die gleiche Netzwerkkarte.
So sind die Dinger immer gleich.
Mir persönlich ist ETH0 auch lieber.
Der nimmt jetzt einfach hardcoded die erste Netzwerkkarte und benennt sie in ETH0 um.
Und das hier ist halt auch, das ist halt Megapog.
hier
haben wir
ein eigenes Linux
also eine eigene Init-ID gebaut
das ist ein Linux
was im RAM läuft
das haben wir selbst gebaut
ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung mehr wo wir das gebaut haben
und wie wir das gebaut haben
Das haben wir im Stream gemacht
Keine Ahnung mehr wie und wo
Und ob ich das auf dem Raspberry Pi gemacht hab oder nicht
Wahrscheinlich hab ich nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi gemacht
Denk ich mal
Weil
Dann wär's ja ein Arm-Image
Also ich hab ehrlich gesagt
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr
Wo und wie wir das hier gebaut haben
Aber das ist halt so ein custom angepasste
Init-ID
Ja, so sieht's aus
Das ist halt
äußerst
advanced
Gut, jetzt hab ich aber lang genug gelabert
Jetzt gucken wir mal kurz auf das Nextcloud
Wobei, wie wir das installiert müssen
wir uns ja nicht angucken
Und dann weiter hier herum.
Beim festlegen im Anschluss, wenn ihr das Ganze speichern wollt,
schaut selbst, ich zeige euch ein Video dazu, unten in der Beschreibung.
Das ist jetzt aber Home Assistant, ne?
Wenn ihr noch etwas erklärt bekommt.
Ich nutze die Servers, hatte die Server-Proben.
Ah, so spannend. Okay, das Video ist wirklich nicht so spannend.
Ich ärgere mich gerade ein bisschen, dass ich nicht mehr weiß,
wo ich das
gebaut hab.
POG Desktop.
Haben wir das vielleicht hier gebaut?
Dieses Custom Debian Image?
Init.RD hast du mit einem Docker-Container gebaut.
Stimmt!
Das hab ich bestimmt noch hier im Stream gemacht, oder?
Ich hab das im Docker-Container gebaut.
Du hast recht.
Was ist das? Nehm ich ein Pfeil?
Full Automatic Installation.
Irgendwelche obskuren Dinger.
Aber ich wette mit euch,
damit kann man nicht alles machen, was ich da gebaut hab.
Mit dem Custom Image.
Das hab ich bestimmt noch in der
VM gebaut, oder?
Wo hab ich denn mein
Docker Setup
Ich hoffe ich hab mir das
Irgendwo gespeichert
Das wäre nämlich echt doof
Hätte ich das verloren
Docker PS
Minus A
What the fuck
Docker in Docker
Vor 4 Monaten
ZFS Bootmenu im Bild
Linux?
Ne.
Okay, da haben wir es schon.
PXE-Boot.
PXE-Boot klingt doch gut.
Aha.
Hier, da habe ich den Kram.
Oder?
Setup.sh?
Ne, das ist das andere.
Äh.
Bild.sh klingt gut.
Ja.
Das ist es.
Das ist das Ding, um das Custom Linux Image zu erstellen.
Was mache ich denn hier?
Bild.pxe boot.
Okay, da müsste es ein Docker-File hier geben.
Da gibt es ein Docker-File.
Docker-File.
Debian Trixi, auf Debian Trixi Base ist das
So, Update, Update
Warum auch zweimal, hat bestimmt seinen Sinn
Install
Den Kernel Geschichte
Job hier für SSH
Crypt Setup wird removed, okay
FZF, LZ4, Curl, WIMPV wird installiert
SSH Keys
Äh
Okay, ja, die müsste ich vielleicht auch mal aktualisieren
Aber gut, man
Die sollte ich mir besser dynamisch vom Server laden.
Das wäre noch viel nicer.
Jetzt muss ich die mal reinschreiben hier.
Get it dynamic from HTTP.
Dynamically from HTTP.
Das wäre noch viel geiler.
So, und dann kopiert er diesen ganzen Kram hier rein.
Update initramfs.
Und dann kopiere ich mir die initramfs quasi raus.
Ja, okay, okay.
Gut, gut. Ich hab den Kram hier gespeichert,
wie ich das baue.
Gut zu wissen.
Exzellent.
Schon abgedrehter Kram, oder?
Ich baue das hier aus.
Nun sind die Nudel kalt. Ach Quatsch, die haben noch einen Deckel drauf.
Das passt.
Chatter, machen wir heute ein bisschen früher Schluss.
Gibt es aktuell Cuts, FPS?
Ne, ich habe aktuell keine eigene Cuts.
Aber mich besucht immer eine.
Und zwar die hier besucht mich täglich.
Ne, ne, der nicht.
Ich habe doch hier die da.
Hier, der Dicke.
Besucht mich regelmäßig.
Der sitzt dann immer bei mir in der Küche.
und guckt mich so an, weil er was haben will.
Der ist gar nicht so
Chonker. Der sieht von vorne so Chonker
aus. Guck mal von oben, ist der überhaupt nicht Chonker.
Das sieht nur auf dem
Bild so aus.
Das ist, by the way,
die gleiche Katz, die ich hier fotografiert
habe. Da.
Das ist die gleiche.
Super entspannte Katz.
Da seht ihr es.
So dick ist der nicht.
Okay Leute, dann
Gehe ich jetzt was futtern
Ihr könnt ja mal bei meinem Alternate Link
Vorbeigucken, Ausrufezeichen Ukraine
Ausrufezeichen Seagate, Ausrufezeichen Alternate
Mal schauen, ob da was für euch
Dabei ist
Gibt's günstige Festplatten und
Ukraine-Nassgeräte
Der Gerät
Jetzt gehe ich was futtern
Bis später dann, oder weiß ich gar nicht
Bis das nächste Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal
So rum ist besser, bis denn, macht's gut, see you